the chair recognizes the member from
auburn representative osborne who moves
at the house adjourned from the session
of february 17 2022. are you ready for
the question all those oppose all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it in
the house is adjourned the house will
attend to a prayer by house chaplain
reverend bob stewart pastor of saint
paul's united methodist church in
manchester
good morning
let's be in a spirit of prayer
oh god you are our help and our hope in
every season of life
we bow before you in distress and
confusion as we watch the events unfold
in the world
that you have created for all humanity
god we pray that you would be in the
midst of the conflicts throughout the
world at this time
o holy one we ask that your mighty hand
be upon the people of ukraine and russia
the people caught in the middle of a war
we pray for those that have been
displaced and have left their homeland
for safety
oh god be with them and
help each to feel your presence as they
face uncertainty today
and in the days that lie ahead
a loving and compassionate god comfort
those that mourn
the loss of a loved one
comfort us oh god as we remember our
friend and colleague
representative renny cushing
who has now been received into your
loving arms
we thank renny for his years of service
to his constituents within the community
he was elected to
we thank representative cushing for
serving this great state as a leader
within this house of representatives
we remember the hymn of promise written
by natalie sleith in 1986
the words that were intended
for each of us
for in the bulb
there is a flower
in a seed
an apple tree
in cocoons
a hidden promise
butterflies
will soon be free
in the cold and snow of winter
there is a spring that waits to be
unrevealed until its season
something god alone can see
oh god of love be with the cushing
family
and give them the strength
courage
and hope that only you can provide
help them to feel your shalom
we gather today to be about the business
of this great state of new hampshire
may you be amongst us this day as
decisions are made for those we
represent
may you guide each member here today and
equip them with the wisdom
needed in making sound decisions for the
people
above all things god may we glorify you
in the way
we lead and the way we work in harmony
with each other
in your glory oh god
amen
the chair recognizes the member from
grab grafton representative les
brazinski who will lead us in the pledge
of allegiance
the united states
the chair recognizes representative bob
green of hudson who will now perform our
national anthem
so
[Music]
[Applause]
the house will attend to request release
of absence
mr speaker the day illness
representatives birch cleaver cohen cody
dauntonville ellis gagne gorg mary
griffin judy miler oxenham pedra peter
schmidt trottier eulery barney white the
day important business representatives
bean
bunker cross egan fontenot kenny
lundgren maggiore mayville macbeth
mckinney mclean prout southworth tudor
and walls
these leaves of absence shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
house will attend to attention to the
induction of guests
mr speaker please welcome hunter porter
student at nashua high school south our
page for the day
[Applause]
mr speaker please welcome jack rowan and
abraham lapointe guests of
representative growing kimberly plojay
daughter of representative plojay
charlie and maxwell post ann and martin
vazquez gail and jack drobat guests of
representative post ellen kolb mike and
juanita dangle guests of representative
notter
laura
alazim guest of representative doug
thomas ralph van biber guest of
representative lebranch the former
member from manchester the honorable
lisa freeman guest of representative
hill and the honorable terry norelli
former speaker of the house guest of the
house they are with us in the gallery
today
[Applause]
welcome to the new hampshire house
the house will now attend to a memorial
house resolution
mr speaker
house resolution number 21
memorializing robert rennie cushing of
hampton
whereas we have learned with great
sorrow of the passing of our colleague
and friend robert rennie cushing
who was serving his eighth term as a
state representative representing the
citizens of rockingham district 21 the
town of hampton and
whereas renny cushing was an advocate
and activist who began a campaign for
change at the age of 15 in this very
chamber he knew that time and
persistence would ultimately bring
change
and whereas a citizen of the world rene
cushing hall trash in atlanta
mined in canada picked fruit in florida
in california and protested for causes
he believed in eventually serving as
chair of the criminal justice committee
where he led compassionately and with
justice in mind
and whereas a trusted leader in this
institution renee cushing sought to
celebrate this state house with its
bicentennial work to include portraits
of deserving women on the walls and
leave it in a better place than he found
it
and whereas serving as the leader of the
largest minority caucus in state history
renny cushing spoke beyond just his
caucus but to the whole house
and whereas above all renee cushing was
a devoted family man who cherished his
time with his wife christy his loving
daughters marie elizabeth and grace
and was surrounded by them in their love
through his illness
now therefore be it resolved by the
house of representatives and regular
session convened
robert rennie cushing be granted the
highest praise and accolades and our
profound thanks for his service to the
state and the town he called home all
his life
and be it further resolved the
expressions of our heart most heartfelt
sympathy be extended to his family and a
suitable copy of this resolution be
prepared for presentation to them
please stand and join me in a moment of
silence and honor and in memory of the
member from hampton the honorable robert
rennie cushing
please join me in welcoming
marie cushing daughter of representative
cushing
[Applause]
the chair recognizes the member from
concord representative mary jane wallner
for
memorial remarks for renny
thank you mr speaker
and thank you fellow house members
today
we remember representative robert randy
closing
to this body he was an eight-term
legislator
the chair of the criminal justice and
public safety committee
and the house democratic leader
a beloved
colleague
and a dear dear friend
to the world he was an organizer for
justice
a fierce advocate for crime victims a
global crusader to end the death penalty
a mentor to young people
an explorer of many countries
and an unyielding lover of humanity
to new hampshire
and to the people of hampton
he was a career helper
and a caring neighbor
he worked his entire life to protect all
granite staters
with special care for the poorest
and most marginalized
among us
while he could be thought of as a
citizen of everywhere
renny adored being from the granite
state
even throughout his valiant battle with
cancer
he often referred to himself as
the luckiest kid in the world
because he was from new hampshire
he was grateful for his present
proud of his past
and encouraged by the future
rennie was a staunch supporter of
education
perpetually boasting about when it
connect high school and his elementary
school hampton central elementary
which was the first public school in new
hampshire
it is difficult for us together in reps
hall without renny here
his presence seems constant
integrated into these very walls
most of us do not know
serving the legislature without him
as an advocate we know him as an
advocate and then as a democratic member
of our staff here at the state house and
as a legislator
he leaves an indelible mark on this
institution
rini's story is
in
intricate to the way of life
the policies and the initiatives he
championed changed the trajectory of new
hampshire
forming a more just and equitable
society
for decades renny worked across the
aisle
to achieve a strong legislative and
political changes
making countless friends
here among us
along the way
rini was here to legalize marriage
equality he championed marijuana
decriminalization
fought tirelessly for a secure
psychiatric unit
and relentlessly protected crime victims
families
he funded the hanging of the portrait of
suffragette
mirella ricker in the state house an
image fit to reflect the power of women
and girls everywhere
rennie's advocacy was always centered
around inclusion and compassion
when he was just 16 years old
in
1969 rene spoke of
voting rights
to 18 19 and 20 year olds from where i
am standing today
50 years later
in 19 in 2019
he was here in the same spot
urging this body
to see
that new hampshire can finally live
without the death penalty
rooney was right
by a single vote in the house and the
senate the death penalty was repealed in
new hampshire
our hearts and thoughts are with
rennie's family
we are forever grateful to them for
sharing rene with us for the past four
decades
rennie led with love and loyalty
to this sacred institution and to all
humankind
he leaves a legacy in new hampshire
and in this body unlike any before him
and unlike any we will see again
the void left with his passing obligates
us all to legislate slate
compassionately
love abundantly
and speak up courageously
for all the good he did and all the good
his example will do
for decades to come we gratefully
remember him
thank you mr speaker
[Applause]
four reason is memorized
without objection
the chair recognizes a member from
kingston representative david walsh from
memorial remarks
thank you mr speaker
i worried last night about what i was
going to say about our colleague
ronnie cushing
i met rennie not face to face but we
were at seabrook together
on opposite sides of the
fence he served on on my committee
criminal justice and eventually became
chairman of that
he fought to make new hampshire a better
place
remain consistent
although we hardly ever agreed
politically
we both had a common purpose
to make new hampshire a better place to
live
and grow our family
for any cushing
you did it
his job well done
condolences to the family of franny
cushing thank you
[Applause]
for what reason is a member rise
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i that
through remarks and my good friend and
mentor
from kingston be placed in the permanent
journal without objection thank you mr
speaker
i'm just going to take a minute for
personal privilege myself
i've known rainey since he was in this
body
and like dave
we didn't agree too often on
philosophical issues
but he was a
true gentleman
and he was a pleasure to work with
and i
consider him
to be a good friend that i've met in
this legislature over the years
thank you
the house will now attend to a house
resolution
mr speaker house resolution number 20
honoring the citizens of ukraine
whereas the new hampshire house of
representatives was deeply troubled to
learn of the military invasion of
ukraine in violation of national
sovereignty and international law
and whereas the international community
is responding to this unwarranted
invasion with financial strategic and
humanitarian support
and whereas the new hampshire house has
a long-standing history of affirming its
support for communities states and
nations throughout the world especially
in times of distress
now therefore be it resolved that the
new hampshire house of representatives
honors the victims of the invasions
offers its condolences to the families
of the victims and applauds the heroic
actions of ukrainian citizens in defense
of their homeland
and be it further resolved that the
house of representatives in regular
session convened stands with the country
of ukraine and offers its support love
and prayers offered by the house of
representatives
please stand for a moment of silence for
the people of ukraine
the house will now attend to the consent
calendar
mr speaker from the committee on
children and family law house bill 1436
removed by representative gay
from the committee on children and
family law house bill 1651 removed by
representative testerman
from the committee on election law house
bill 1149 removed by representative
abramson
from the committee on election law house
bill 1197 removed by representative
lebranch
from the committee on executive
departments and administration house
bill 1443 removed by representative muse
from the committee on labor industrial
and rehabilitative services
house bill 1124 removed by
representative bernardi
from the committee on resources
recreation and development hospital 1555
removed by representative burke
and from the committee on ways and means
house bill 1509 removed by
representative horrigan
are there any other bills to be removed
representative osborne moves at the
consent calendar with the relevant
amendments as printed in the day's house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the
consent calendar is adopted it's in a
fault or declared conflicts of interest
and did not participate in the vote on
the consent calendar
the house will now attend to bills on
the regular calendar
the committee on criminal justice and
public safety to which was referred
house bill 1011fn
an act relative
to the penalty for criminal mischief
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass senator david walsh
for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee report is
adopted
the committee on criminal justice and
public safety to which was referred
house bill 1031
an act prohibiting law enforcement from
encrypting public frequencies having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is an inexpedient to legislate senator
david walsh for the committee are you
ready
thank you mr speaker i wish to make a
motion to table
hb
1031.
okay that is a proper motion
the motion before us is to table house
bill 1031 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and
one zero three one is laid on the table
majority of the
committee on criminal justice and public
safety to which was referred house bill
fn
enact prohibiting the display of a
deadly weapon at a parade funeral
possession picket line march rally
vigil or demonstration having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator john
burt from the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senate david news for the minority
of the committee
the chair recognizes representative muse
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
one of the most precious rights we have
as citizens is our first amendment right
to raise our voices in protest
or in support of changes that we as
citizens would like to see
protecting this right and ensuring that
people are free to speak out at rallies
and demonstrations without fear of
intimidation is the very act of
protecting democracy itself
since the start of 2020
weapons toting protesters and counter
protesters have been spotted at
demonstrations in portsmouth concord
nashua and manchester
but these events are just the tip of an
iceberg
according to the armed conflict location
and event data project a group that
collects data and reports on political
violence worldwide
over 610 armed demonstrations have been
reported around the country since the
start of 2020.
the group also reports that armed
demonstrations are 6.5 times more likely
to turn violent or destructive than
demonstrations where no firearms are
present
hb 1151 is a bill that seeks to protect
first amendment rights
second amendment rights and most
important of all
human lives
hb 1151 would ban the open carrying of
firearms within 100 feet of a protest
rally of march
for any first amendment related activity
that takes place on any public property
despite what you may have been told or
what you may soon hear
the right to self-defense is preserved
under this bill
while the bill restricts open carry it
protest
it has a
specific exemption for concealed carry
so if being armed makes you feel safer
you can carry a weapon
but what you can't do is carry it out in
the open within a hundred feet of other
people expressing their first amendment
rights
over the years our courts have
repeatedly ruled that it does not
violate the second amendment for
government to prohibit firearms at
public events
currently seven states along with the
district of columbia
bar firearms at rallies
among these states are alabama and north
carolina
something worth noting is that there is
an important exemption exception that
was written into the bill at the
suggestion of the new hampshire
chapter of the american civil liberties
union
demonstrations or protests with the
specific purpose of supporting second
amendment rights are exempt under the
bill
so open carry would be allowed when the
primary purpose of the rally is to
support
second amendment rights
the bottom line is that hb 1151 is a
good faith attempt to better protect the
safety and rights of citizens engaged in
first amendment activities
while also protecting their right to
self-defense
please overturn the committee
recommendation so another motion can be
made
thank you
before we get on to
the final speaker
i just want to let everybody know how
this is going to work
if i know there's going to be a roll
call or a division vote
i'm going to announce how many speakers
are going to be speaking
when the last speaker is going to speak
i'm going to announce whether it's going
to be a roll call or a division vote
and everybody is i'm going to ask
everybody to return to their seats
because we're going to go immediately
into a vote we're not going to be
waiting five six seven minutes for
people to come in from the ante room or
to sit down
so
we've got a lot to do today and we've
got an awful lot to do next week so
we're going to have to move this process
along
so having said that
i'm announcing the final speaker
representative abbas
thank you mr speaker
i rise in support of the committee's
recommendation of index being to
legislate
just to clarify a few
points that have been raised
to threaten an individual is already a
crime
an existing law in new hampshire if you
threaten an individual using a firearm
actually is an enhanced penalty and is a
felony
the problem with hp
1151 is that it's both with its
application
and enforcement creates confusion
amongst the general public because of
the overly broad terminology used in in
the drafting
the goal was to prevent a individual
from open carrying a firearm or
a deadly weapon which would include a
pocket knife
from being able to open carry that
within a hundred feet of any type of
first amendment demonstration that's
occurring on public property
there is no exception if you are
standing on private property so that
political demonstration does not
necessarily have to be noticed it can be
spontaneous
as long as you're a spectator which
means you're looking in the general
direction of this spontaneous
demonstration
if you're open carrying a firearm on on
your front lawn if you're within 100
feet of that
you would be violating the law
and i would also point out that these
parades and marches and demonstrations
are
often mobile which means you may be
outside the radius of
100 feet but because the demonstration
is moving in your direction
you would then be violating the law by
simply standing there minding your own
business it would also
apply to an individual who's driving a
vehicle
who doesn't even know that there's a
demonstration happening
there is an exception if you have a gun
rack in a pickup truck a pickup truck
only not a van
suv
camper but
you see my point
so i asked i asked everyone to
join me in pushing that green button in
supporting the committee's
recommendation of inexpedient to
legislation thank you mr speaker
president of bel desairo has asked for a
roll call vote is that sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded
members will take their seats
[Music]
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes
representative bradley for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that firearms and
protests are a dangerous mix
and if i know this bill not only
balances the first and second amendment
rights
but protects both
then when i press the red button to
defeat the itl motion so another motion
can be made
before we get to the next pi
you have to turn for those of you that
are new in the house you might have to
hit your
white button first be so you can vote
the chair recognizes representative
burke for parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker
if i know
i
and many of my friends open carry and
love
to go to second amendment rallies
demonstrations
marches
which if house bill 1151 would pass into
law would make it illegal
mr speaker
if i know
if i or any of my open carry friends
walk within a hundred feet of a parade
funeral possession or other similar
events we will unknowingly
be breaking
the law
if house bill 1151 passes
and lastly mr speaker if i know house
bill 1151 is not
the new hampshire way
because we have constitutional carry
and we have to live free or die state
would i now press the very bright green
button
to itl this bill thank you
mr speaker
the question is on the majority
ito motion on house bill 1151
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
i'm not sure who's doing the whistling
out there but that is not an acceptable
practice in this house
[Music]
thumbs up for thumbs down please thank
you
thumbs up and thumbs down
representative schmidt
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
household 10 to the state of the vote
192 voting yay 141 voting a committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred house bill 1175
an act relative to recording
interactions with public officials
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate senator amy bradley for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative chris true
from the minority other committee
for what reason does a member rise thank
you mr speaker i wish to make a motion
to table hb 1175 stage of motion
motion to table
motion to table is a correct motion
ocean before us is the table house bill
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
that's paul's name
the eyes have it and 1175 is laid on the
table
committee on criminal justice and public
safety to which was referred house bill
1281 fn
an act relative to access to firearms
confiscated from a person who is subject
to a protective order having considered
the same report the same the
recommendation that the bill
be referred for interim study
representative terry roy for the
committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
all opposed nay
the eyes have it and
the report is adopted
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which has
referred house bill 1282
an act relative to records of
communication
common carriers
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative terry
roy for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
david news for the minority of the
committee
uh for what reason is a member rise
i wish to make a motion stage of motion
i wish the table is built
it is a proper motion
the motion before us it's a table house
bill
one two eight two are you
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
representative roy has requested a
division vote
the chair recognizes representative muse
for a parliamentary inquiry
are you in favor of supporting the table
the chair recognizes representative berg
j recognizes representative byrd for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker
if i know
law enforcement went
to the phone company's 43 times from
2018 to 2021
and got phone records of citizens
without a search warrant
mr speaker if i know law enforcement can
get a search warrant within just minutes
with a phone call
it does not take that long
and lastly mr speaker if i know
one search of a new hampshire citizen's
phone record without a valid search
warrant is one too many in the live free
or die state would i now press
the red button so another motion may be
made thank you mr speaker
the chair recognizes representative muse
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the current
subpoena process used by the attorney
general is used rarely and helps jump
start investigations into child sexual
abuse images
and if i know that passing this bill may
unintentionally slow these
investigations down
while also increasing the risk of
potentially embarrassing but not
criminal personal information being
mishandled or disclosed
and if i know the criminal justice and
public safety committee heard no
testimony that the current process is
being abused and heard no evidence that
it's be that it's broken then would i
press the green button and support the
tabling motion
thank you
the question is the tabling motion on
house bill 1282
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
so
represent rogers
representative rogers
representative
representative wolf
yes or no please
thank you
representative testerman
representative perez
it's not going to work after the 30
seconds closing thank you
mr speaker
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
also attend to the state of the vote
160 voting yay 174 voting nay the motion
to table fails
we're now back to the original motion of
ought to pass
the
chair recognize we have two speakers
the chair recognizes representative
harriet garth wright to speak against
the committee report
uh
if she wants to wave
so
thank you
mr speaker
i rise today in opposition to the art to
pass motion for hb
while the intent of this bill is good
we learned in our hearing that it may
have unintended consequences that could
slow down the investigation of child
sexual abuse images in our state
the department of justice informed us
that 60 to 70 percent of these issues
are
due
to child criminal charges
under our current law the new hampshire
attorney general's office has the power
to issue an administrative subpoena that
requires cell phone or internet carriers
to confirm whether
traffic from a suspected i p address
involves the customer
the request we heard about
about 40
about 40 40 a year come from internet
crimes units of state and local law
enforcement
if a carrier that receives a subpoena
matches an ip address to a customer it
notifies the ag's office
it also provides the customer
name and address the types of service
they purchase and billing records
at that point a search warrant can be
requested from the court for additional
information from the carrier that is not
available
under an administrative subpoena
the bottom line is that under our
current process the most sensitive
information
like websites visited email records
email content require additional
authorization from a judge
the two-step process does two things
first it allows the ag office to quickly
get information back from carriers about
a potential hit
this is critically
critically important in cases where
victimization of a child may be ongoing
and second it loops in a judge in order
to limit the flow of more sensitive
personal information by requiring a
search warrant for it
if we pass this bill search warrants may
go out to multiple carriers at first
step
this means the most sensitive personal
information which doesn't always include
criminal activity has the potential to
come back from more sources
more information from more sources means
a greater chance of non-criminal
information being seen and potentially
mishandled
so
is the current process if the current
process allows investigations of child
abuse images to be jump started and
quickly narrowed and targeted
we heard testimony from ag's office that
the process is used extremely
selectively and serves a valuable
function
we heard no testimony at all that the
current process is being abused
instead we heard this bill slows down
these investigations and may also have
the unintended consequences of gathering
personal information from innocent
parties that while not criminal could
prove unnecessary and potentially
embarrassing
for these reasons we're asking that you
vote against the art to pass motion so
another motion may be made thank you
a division has been requested by
representative roy members will take
their seats
the chair recognizes representative roy
to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
i'd like to start by apologizing for
that
that table motion i was so excited to
get us out of here early i jumped the
gun on that
so on this bill
the citizens of new hampshire have
spoken
we just passed or the citizens just
passed a constitutional amendment that
would guarantee their privacy
all this bill does
is it pays attention to what the
citizens of new hampshire just told us
they want
if a law enforcement agency wants your
information from a common carrier for a
criminal investigation they should have
to follow the same rules as if they
wanted to go into your house and search
your computer
they should have to get a search warrant
and it's not a high bar it's probable
cause in layman's terms more likely than
not they just have to show that it's
more likely than not that you committed
a crime and therefore they need your
telephone records
it's not hard
it would take them an hour to get a
search warrant properly executed
so all i'm asking and all we're asking
is that we listen to the people of new
hampshire who just voted
for privacy and protection in their
records and personal effects
thank you very much and i would ask you
to vote green
sir roy has requested a division vote
members will be in their seats the chair
recognizes representative muse for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know this bill has unintensive
consequences that
that i think we'd all like to avoid that
it could slow down attorney general's
investigations into
child sexual abuse images which is
probably
one of the most horrible crimes on our
on our books
if i know that if i also know that
providing
all of the data
that would be required to properly
investigate a case like this
in
the first uh
basically in the first group of data
that
that is shared could compromise uh
personal information that is not
criminal uh from people who are not
engaged in these activities
then would i press
the red button so another motion can be
made thank you
chair recognized representative burt for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that law
enforcement went to the phone companies
43 times from 2018 to 2021 and got phone
records of new hampshire citizens
without a search warrant
mr speaker if i know law enforcement can
get a search warrant within
i guess that's an hour
i heard it was a little less with just a
phone call
and lastly mr speaker if i know one
search of a new hampshire citizen's
phone records without a valid search
warrant
is one too many in the live free or die
state would i press now
the green button thank you mr speaker
question is on the majority ought to
pass motion on house bill 1282 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
there's
if all members president opportunity to
vote
house will attend a state of the vote
under 97 voting a 137 voting a committee
report is adopted
committee on criminal justice and public
safety to which was referred house bill
1483 an act relative to the use of
physical force by a law enforcement
officer having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate senator dale abbas for the
committee
chair recognizes
representative
true to speak against the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
rsa 627 colon 5
lists three justifications for a police
officer to use deadly force
one to defend himself or a third person
from what he reasonably believes is the
imminent use of deadly force
two to effect an arrest
or three
to prevent the escape from custody of a
person whom he reasonably believes has
committed or is committing a felony
involving the use of force or violence
is using a deadly weapon in attempting
to escape or otherwise indicates he's
likely to seriously endanger human life
or inflict serious bodily injury
unless apprehended without delay
house bill 1483 proposes two changes to
the rsa concerning the use of deadly
force
by a police officer
one it removes reasonably beliefs
from the rsa
because what a person reasonably
believes is subjective
it is the
new hampshire attorney general and or
the courts that make the determination
of the reasonableness of the use of
deadly force
based on objective facts not subjective
beliefs
the other change to the rsa is that it
removes the words to affect an arrest
since we heard in testimony from new
hampshire law enforcement
that they would never
use deadly force simply to factor an
arrest
removing those words from the new
hampshire rsa should not affect the
actions of the police at all
on page 21 of the calendar
you will see that the majority blurb
states that house bill 1483
would prohibit
the use of deadly force by a police
officer when affecting an arrest when
the subject has committed or is
committing a felony involving the use of
force or violence
using a deadly weapon and attempting to
escape
nowhere in house bill 1483
does it state in fact
such a prohibition
house bill 1483 does not prohibit the
use of deadly force by a police officer
to defend himself
or to defend others
house bill 1483 does not prohibit the
use of deadly force by a police officer
to prevent the escape of someone
committing a felony using force or
violence
house bill 1483 does not prohibit the
use of deadly force to stop an attempted
escape of a person who is using a deadly
weapon
notwithstanding what is said in the
majority blurb the reason you do not
hear anything about prohibition in house
bill 1483 is because the word doesn't
exist in the bill
thank you mr speaker does the member
yield to questions
the member does not yield
gerrick and isis representative abbess
speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker i rise in support
of the committee's recommendation of nxp
in expedient to legislate this bill hb
1483 would prohibit a police officer
from
using deadly force in the process of
affecting an arrest when a a
suspect has
is using deadly uh using a deadly weapon
to help facilitate their escape
or as otherwise indicates that
that suspect is posing a
serious danger to human life
the only testimony that we heard
during the public hearing
in support of hb
used an example of someone who stole
clothes from a department store and was
running away
and as that individual was running away
if the police were to shoot that person
in the back
that would they believe that that would
be legal under new hampshire law in fact
that it would be under the existing law
today
that would be against the law
that would be excessive force
and that would be a crime
therefore
the rationale and the testimony
presented to the committee
would not actually resolve the concerns
raised
that
inspired filing this bill
in respect to
the police officers
who risked their lives to protect us and
to keep us safe
and we we want to ask them to continue
to do that
however if someone is using a deadly
weapon trying to escape
we want to tell the same police officers
that they cannot use deadly force
themselves
if a suspect is engaging in behavior
that would seriously endanger
human lives
and we expect a police officer now to
arrest that person
however they would not be permitted to
use
deadly force when affecting that arrest
hb 1483 not only jeopardizes the safety
of police officers
it puts the general public's safety at
risk as well
because it prohibits it obstructs police
officers from doing their duty to try to
save us when we we are in a
life-threatening situation
so please join me
and push the green button and support
the committee's recommendation of nxp
and to legislate thank you mr speaker
question before us is the ito motion on
house bill 1483
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
committee on criminal justice and public
safety to which was referred house bill
act relative to prohibitions on carrying
a loaded firearm on a no hrv or
snowmobile considered the same report
the same with the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass
john burt for the committee
chair recognizes representative bradley
to speak against the committee report
[Music]
thank you mr speaker
for many years states like new hampshire
have banned the practice of allowing
allowing loaded weapons on atvs and
snowmobiles
the rationale is if you've ever been
around guns and off-road vehicles you
know how bumpy the ride can get how an
accidental spill or collision is always
a risk
and how dangerous a loaded gun can be
when it's dropped or mishandled
currently in both new hampshire and
minnesota you may carry a firearm in an
atv or snowmobile if it's unloaded
in both states law enforcement officers
carrying weapons while on duty are
exempt
as they are in other states with similar
laws
the idea isn't to inconvenience gun
owners it's to reduce the risk of a
preventable tragedy
what hb 1636 does is to invite tragedy
by making an exception for carrying
loaded pistols on atvs and snowmobiles
by anyone not prohibited by new
hampshire law from carrying a firearm
aside from adding an unwanted element of
extra risk you have to wonder how the
possibility of sharing the trails with
people carrying loaded weapons
is going to sit with many of the
families
from in-state and out-of-state who have
recently taken up off-roading and
snowmobiling
the bottom line is this bill makes a
sport that many people in the north
country depend on for income less
attractive
to the very people whose interest and
engagement provide the best chance for
it to grow
please join me in opposing this bill
the chair made a
mistake
we have two speaking for the committee
report one against i should have called
representative abramson before i did
representative bradley
i apologize but we'll have two in a row
that'll be speaking before i
um
it's kind of like a new new gig up here
i'm getting used to it so uh
i'm probably going to make an occasional
mistake but i hope everybody will
take that into consideration thank you
chair recognize representative abramson
to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker i want to apologize
for new members always turn your uh
phones off or turn them to silent i rise
in uh support of the uh ought to pass
motion on house bill 13 sorry 1636
relative to allowing people who have a
ohrv
to uh have a loaded firearm on firearm
and i've asked this question a number of
times and i still have not gotten a
response what happens if somebody's out
in the woods
out in the winter out in the snow and
they have their firearm with them and
it's loaded and they need to get home
is is the requirement that they have to
throw their their
firearm onto the trail into the snow
do they have to unload the weapon do
they have to pull the bolt or the slide
back and eject the cartridge into the
snow and lose it
and i i felt that this was a safety
issue that we did not want to have
people out there who are miles away from
anyone
and having to leave either
firearms or ammunition on the trail so
for that reason i
am in support of this bill and i'm
asking members to vote green
representative burt has requested roll
call
he is the final speaker so members take
your seats this will be a roll call vote
if it's sufficiently seconded
i would assume it will be
it is sufficiently seconded so this will
be a roll call vote
go ahead representative
thank you
mr speaker
this is the third time for this bill
it's a housekeeping bill
what it does is we have constitutional
carry in new hampshire
when constitutional carry was passed
there was a
law that
nobody knew was sitting there in fish
and game that said if you
are riding a snowmobile or a four
wheeler you cannot carry a loaded
firearm
so
the ag would like to have this language
cleaned up
and there's a couple ways to do it
repeal constitutional carry no
or repeal this small bill
yes
mr speaker
one thing that's very important
if you have a new hampshire concealed
carry license
you can carry on a snowmobile regardless
if this law is here or not
and also mr speaker when i keep bringing
this bill back
everybody that i know that rides
snowmobile and four-wheelers they all
say john is that really a law
and i tell them yes
because they don't know that it is so
most people are carrying
in this time mr speaker i even actually
talked to fishing game
and they support the repeal of this bill
or this this um
law that i'm trying to repeal so mr
speaker what i'm hoping
is to keep this
bill house bill 1636 amendment free
so it can go to the corner office where
it will be signed so as long as we can
do that and it's going to come out of
this house amendment free
so please vote
green
because that is the right way to do to
make sure that we have constitutional
carry on all forms of transportation
thank you mr speaker
this will be a roll call vote
members being will be in your seats
the chair recognizes representative
expedia for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill would allow for
the open carrying firearms on a
snowmobile or atv and if i know that the
risk of accidental discharge due to an
accident bump or spill presents a danger
to anyone in this in the vicinity and if
i further know that preventing acts of
gun violence is critical to making the
granite states of granite state a place
where we can all thrive would i now
press the red button so another emotion
can be made
chair recognizes representative rory for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that if you have a license to carry
you can currently already carry on an
atv
mr speaker if i know that law
enforcement currently carries loaded
weapons on atvs without
fear of bumping and discharging their
weapons
if i know that they have not had any
accidents and lastly mr speaker if i
know that you can carry a loaded firearm
in your vehicle and i don't know about
you mr speaker but the roads are very
just as bumpy as if i was off-roading
right now and there are no discharges
going on would i press green to fix this
bill thank you very much mr speaker
question is on the ought to pass motion
on house bill 1636
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're approached you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
204 voting yay 134 voting a committee
report is adopted
committee on executive departments and
administration to which has referred
house bill 1037
an act relative to the governor's duties
during a state of emergency having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendations the bill ought to pass
with amendment
representative diane schuett for the
committee amendment is zero zero seven
one h printed in house record nine page
thirty four are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have the eyes have it an
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is the
motion on
house bill 107 103 7
ought to pass with amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
majority committee on executive
department's administration to which was
referred house bill 1059
clarifying limits on licensure by
operation of law having considered the
same report the same the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative jeff golly for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate serve tony
lacus for the minority of the committee
the question before you is the ought to
pass motion on house
bill
1059 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
no member can come in we're in the
voting mode right now
this is a division vote
if you're in favor
of the ought to pass motion you press
the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
represent mcaleer
thumbs up or thumbs down please
representative callum
you'll have to
representative
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
else will attend to the state of the
vote
177 voting yay 157 voting a the
committee report is adopted
majority of committee on executive
departments administration to which was
referred house bill 1159 an act
recognizing november 7th as victim of
communism memorial day considered the
same we
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate
it's in mass on the tunnel for the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendations the bill ought to pass
representative michael jacobovich for
the minority of the committee
for what member does the
reason remember reason this member rise
for emotion
stage emotion i move to table
the motion is a proper motion the motion
is before us the table
house bill
1159 a division has been requested
members will take
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it's not sufficiently seconded
division this is where your division
vote
[Music]
she's against
this is a division vote
the motion is the table house bill one
one five nine
the chair recognizes representative
prude
ryan for
to speak against the tabling motion
it's a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if you know as i know that this is an
important bill
and that we should have a vote on it and
that this is a timely bill and that we
should have a vote on it to express our
our position on that
i ask you to press the red button and
vote no on table
j i recognize representative mcguire for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that
november 7th is already a federal
holiday as victims of communism day
and if i know that the governor will be
delighted to
declare a state holiday upon request
and if i know this bill is not worth our
time and energy to debate would i now
press the green button and table it
the motion before us is a tabling motion
on house bill 1159
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
kimball
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
281 voting
yay 55 voting nay
the motion to table house bill 1159 is
adopted
majority of the committee on executive
departments administration to which was
referred house bill 1257 fn an act
requiring the retirement system to
divest from investment in companies
located in china having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is in expedient
to legislate
jc grotty for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee locate having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass
representative sally fellows for the
minority of the committee
are you ready for the question
all those
[Music]
who
who requested a roll call
representative le branch requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote
members take your seats this will be a
roll call vote
so
this is going to be a roll call vote
members will be in their seats
chair recognizes representative mcguire
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that the
state constitution requires all funds
in the retirement system be invested
solely for the benefit
of the people receiving pensions
and if i know that the trustees of the
retirement position
retirement system have determined that
this bill would cause them to violate
their constitutional requirement would i
not press the green button thank you
the question is on the majority report
have been expedient to legislate
on house bill 1257 fn this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
representative loseless
[Music]
representative chase
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
312 voting yeah 25 voting a
the committee report is adopted
representative harrington declared a
conflict and did not participate
just so everybody remembers i know it's
been a while since we've been here but
once the 30 seconds is up you can't use
your machine at that point
you have to respond to the clerk
committing on executive departments and
administration to which was referred
house bill 1460fn
act relative to minimum age requirements
for certain occupational licenses having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it's inexpedient to legislate senator
william marsh for the committee are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report's
adopted
majority of the committee on
majority of the committee on fish and
game and marine resources to which was
referred house built
nine nine
and act relative the process for the
importation
it's getting awful noisy in here
and act relative to the process for the
importation of wildlife and creating an
appeal process for denials or permits
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation of the bill ought to
pass with amendment
timothy lying from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority or report with
the recommendation that the bill re be
referred for interim study senator
catherine harvey from the minority of
the committee
the amendment is
01508 printed in house record nine pages
is 40.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the question before us now is
the ought to pass with amendment motion
on house bill 1299
a division has been requested but there
are only parliamentary inquiries so
members will take your seats
uh
here
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on house bill 1299
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative harvey for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that house bill
1299 opens the possibility of the
introduction of invasive species into
our state of new hampshire
and mr speaker if i know that the new
hampshire commissioners
do not have the power to serve as an
appeal board as per rsa nor do they want
that power
and mr speaker if i know that the
director of new hampshire fish and game
has the experience and knowledge of fish
and game wildlife departments to either
deny or approve wildlife importation
where commissioners may not have that
luxury would i now press the red button
so that another motion may be brought
forward thank you mr speaker
the chair recognizes representative lang
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that at its heart this bill is a
due process bill that protects our
citizens here in new hampshire and mr
speaker if i know this bill does two
things the first of which
sets a timeline that the department must
respond to a citizen's request as the
current law would let them just hold the
request forever and never respond and mr
speaker if i know the second thing this
does is creates an appeal process so if
the citizen does not agree with the
department it can go to the commission
and appeal the decision of the
department to the fish and game
commission which sets policy for the
fish and game department would i now
push the green button so the citizens
can have fair access to the fish and
game appeal process
the question before us is the ought to
pass as amended report majority report
on house bill 1299
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
183 voting yeah 155 voting a committee
report is adopted
majority of committee on health and
human services and elderly affairs to
which was referred house bill 1126
an act permitting minors over the age of
16 to obtain a vaccination without
parental consent considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate
senator bill king for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same
and being unable to agree with the
majority report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative joe shapiro for the
minority of the committee
we have two speakers
and a roll call has been requested
so members will please remain in their
seats or come back to their seats i will
get to the second in motion in a minute
the chair recognizes representative
shapiro to speak against the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
hb 1126 will allow adolescents 16 years
and older to acquire fda approved
vaccines without parent or guardian
consent
there are many parents who beset by
substance use or other significant life
issues
are rendered unable to provide adequate
structure support and guidance to their
children
unfortunately this means that some new
hampshire children
suffer chronic passive neglect
others end up homeless and subsisting on
their own
new hampshire statutes already provide
for consent to diagnosis and treatment
of stds and substance use disorder at 14
and 12 years of age respectively
many states at the age of consent for
various kinds of health care at 16 or
even younger
currently minors while able to consent
to sexual activity prior to 18 years of
age are not able to acquire the
human
papilloma virus vaccines without parent
consent
we know that the hpv vaccine is highly
effective in preventing cervical cancer
but only if received prior to exposure
to the virus
prior to the adolescent becoming
sexually active
as with so many issues there are
benefits and consequences on both sides
of this equation
parents we know have rights
and responsibilities
but in the end successful parenting
involves a contract of caring and
communication with their children
parents who afford strong family bonds
will lose nothing with this legislation
their adolescent children will be eager
or at least willing to discuss what is
best for their health
while conceding that there are
legitimate arguments to be made on both
sides the minority believes that
allowing 16 year olds to consent to
vaccines is a measured and reasonable
change in statute that will increase
access to essential preventative health
care for a vulnerable population
if you believe that we have a
responsibility to protect the health of
those without responsible and capable
adults in their lives if you believe
that adolescents deserve access to
critical immunizations
if you believe that even one life may be
saved because of this important
legislation
please push the red button so that
another motion may be made
thank you
chair recognizes representative bill
king
speak for the
majority in the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
as a freshman legislature
i have been learning how legislation can
create laws for a few
that then affect many
also i have often seen where we create
bills that try to solve symptoms and not
the root cause of a problem
house bill 1126 is one of those bills
you will hear that and you have heard
that we need to give 16 year olds the
choice to vaccinate or not because they
are from a family that does not provide
adequate structure
for the child to make informed choices
for them
these kids can end up homeless or
otherwise living on their own
my heart breaks for these kids
living through these tough situations
but to make a law enabling them to
vaccinate or not
make a choice to vaccinate or not is not
good for these kids
whose parents are involved with
understanding
is i'm sorry is not good for those kids
whose parents are involved with
understanding the adverse effects that
sometimes arise after a vaccination
you will also hear that we have other
laws allowing minors the ability to make
choices without parental assistance
although this is true it does not mean
that it's right in this situation
in my opinion the root cause behind the
need this bill addresses is related to
breakdown
related to the breakdown of the family
unit
we as parents accept the responsibility
of researching the risk reward behind
the decisions we make for our kids
most kids are not ready or capable of
making tough decisions like vaccinating
or not
me personally i have four kids
a daughter our oldest followed by three
boys
i am proud of all of them and they are
good kids
however
as for making complex decisions with
dire consequences
i would not allow them all to make a
choice to vaccinate before the age of
18.
my daughter is bright
mature and well researched when she
makes a decision
she has been this way from a very young
age
the boys on the other hand
well
need i say more
in their defense they have become bright
mature
and sort of well-read
researched today
but it happened long after they turned
after the age of 16.
we need to help these kids without
responsible parents in adequate
structure but allowing them to make
their own decisions about vaccines
vaccinations is not the appropriate way
to proceed
please join me in voting inexpedient to
legislate by selecting the shiny green
button
senator pearson has called for a roll
call as that's officially seconded
it is officially seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your seats
so
members take your seats house will be in
order
the question before us is the
inexpedient to legislate majority report
in house bill 1126
this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative weber for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that we have much work ahead of us to
strengthen family bonds
but if i also know that we have right
now 16 year olds and 17 year olds
who have the maturity
and the understanding
and the very desperate need because of
family neglect or in ability to help
them with these decisions
to make the decisions for themselves
and we ought to make it explicit that
they have that right
would i now press the red button so
another motion can be made thank you mr
speaker
jerick and i as representative mark
pearson for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the united states supreme
court's decision in pierce versus
society of sisters said in part
a child is not the mere creature of the
state
and if i know that this bill is but the
first of what will be this year a parade
of bills seeking to remove the
fundamental role and responsibility of
parents
would i not support the motion of itl
and would i know push the green button
thank you mr speaker
the question is on the majority report
of indicating to legislate on house bill
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
household 10 to the state of the vote
184 voting yay 151 voting a committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on judiciary
to which was referred
cacr21
act relating to registers of probate
providing that eliminating the officer
registration probate and all the
references to such office have been
considered the same report the same of
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass senator kurt walper from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and be
enabled to agree with the majority
report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate senator timmy horrigan from
the minority of the committee
this is a one-on-one debate the chair
recognizes
representative horrigan to speak against
the committee report
it's getting awful loud in here
i've i've heard british thank you very
much mr speaker
i guess first of all this will
automatically be a division vote if i'm
not mistaken because we need to uh an
exact count of how many members are for
or against it because
um
anyway this is a register of probate
you've all seen it down at the bottom of
the bottom of the ballot it's one of
those relatively little known county
offices
it actually
gets as many as votes as the ones that
have
more power and higher salaries so
actually they pay pretty generously 100
a year so they're doing
they're doing pretty well um
my first first reason to vote against
the ought to pass is um this is a poorly
drafted resolution or bill or whatever
you want to call it it
only eliminates one of the two direct
references to the officers or register
of probate the constitution so it would
um it would still be
it would still the office would still
exist in the constitution even if this
passed
also the
also any chr can't
can't automatically eliminate a
constitutional office such as a
registered probate
because there's many many references in
the statute law
to it and those would all remain in fact
i think
um
i think i and i think as uh i had a i
got a phone call yesterday from
secretary bill garner he pointed out
that like even if
even if this passed they still have to
elect a registered probate because
there's also a statute law saying that
we have to elect a registered probate
and i think we should
continue electing the registers of
probate
they
they have a small but crucial function
which is still worthwhile we've even
even strengthened it back in 2017 when
we
passed the bill explicitly authorizing
them to work with the state archivist on
preserving historically
significant probate records and i also
think
we need to look at some point in
expanding the role of the registers of
probate because um
they have a role
they had a role that was like that
was not entirely judiciary so like
replacing the resolutions of probate
with just the circuit court clerks i
think was not a good idea even though
the probate division works great and
they have made a lot of good changes so
i think
restoring the registers of probate in
the future would uh would make the
probate
chords and its function even better but
in the in the meantime
meantime i urge my colleagues please
please do not take this
remove the one reference
of the two references to the register
probate let's leave this part of the
constitution alone and let's
let's continue electing them i will say
if you look at the vote counts it's
comparable to those to the other county
offices and actually they have in many
cases elected some very talented people
to the position who take their job
seriously so i think this job does have
value but the first thing to do is uh
vote no on the ought to pass thanks
does the member yield the questions
yes
remember yields remain choir
thank you mr speaker i just want to
understand what you said the bill is
flawed because we miss one section of
the constitution
on the ballot that needs to go to the
people so they understand what they're
voting for did i get that right
yes i believe you did get it right and
thank you probably explain it more
clearly than i did but yes there's
two direct references to register a
probate in the state constitution and
this one only eliminates i believe it's
part one article 71 and they
they're still mentioned in part two
article 81 and probably
probably
there's a few indirect references and
them also
we would have needed some statute well
anyway yes
you're exactly right i thank the member
from goffstown she's 110 correct thanks
this is going to be a division vote
members will take their seats
the last speaker
is coming up
the chair recognizes representative
walper to speak in favor of the
committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
12 years ago we reformed the court
system and moved the duties
of the register of probate
into the court system
this has worked
wonderfully in our states the probate
system works far faster much more
efficiently
and with much fewer
difficulties now
than it has in the past
now this bill doesn't deal directly with
that because the registrar of probate
office
doesn't do anything
so for the past five election cycles
we have elected registers of probate
who get a check
they have no office space
they have no phones they have no
duties
and mr speaker i believe
that it's time that we corrected that
anomaly in our constitution which is
what the register of probate really
comes down to it's like the buggy whip
it's long past time
when it should go away
so
we
initially and i was co-sponsor of a
couple of these bills
tried to restore
the duties to the registers of probate
they failed miserably
miserably
the costs the difficulty of doing it
that was the complexity of trying to
establish a space and offices and things
like that just
was beyond being done
so it's time that we
updated the
constitution to where we are today
and i urge people to support this cacr
this is going to be a division vote the
motion before us on cacr 21 is the
majority report about to pass
the chair recognizes representative
trottier for a parliamentary inquiry
okay
i haven't got it listed here
i haven't got a listed representative
right be recognized for pi
he may be recognized
just basically
this this cacr it's unnecessary it
doesn't
oh
maybe i shouldn't have asked to do api
if i know
that that the office of register of
probate has some value if i if i also
know that this cacr is badly drafted and
doesn't even do what it sets out to do
when i then press the red button so an
alternative motion may be introduced
thank you
chair recognizes representative gordon
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that the
founders anticipated
that at times it would be appropriate to
mend our constitution
and if i know
that there is no longer a need for our
counties to elect registers of probate
that by that if i know by changing that
job over the years we have saved the
stock state
millions of dollars
would i press the green button and
support
the
cacr 21 and the recommendation of the
committee of ought to pass
the question before us is the majority
report about to pass on cacr21
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
representative perez
president had an opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
294 voting yay 43 voting nay
235 needed to pass
committee report is adopted
the committee on judiciary to which was
referred house bill 1013
not relative to meeting of the new
hampshire rare disease advisory council
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that it's inexpensive to
legislate
presented michael sylvia for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
committee on judiciary to which was
referred house bill
1021 an act prohibiting regulation of
religious land use based on the
religious nature of the assembly or
speech taking place on the land or in
the structure having considered the same
report the same the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass
representative current walper for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the eyes haven't
committed reporters adopted
committee on judiciary to which was
referred house bill
1205 an act allowing the department of
environmental services to have access to
enhanced 911 information
having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
president of ned
gordon for the committee
the committee amendment is 0404
h printed in house of record 9 pages
38-39 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it in the amendment is
adopted the question before us now is
the motion of ought to pass with
amendment
house bill 1205. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
committee on judiciary to which was
referred house bill 1216 fn
an act repealing the housing appeals
board having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
that it is inexpedient to legislate
senator marjorie smith for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
committee on judiciary to which was
referred house bill 1254
an act relative to the housing housing
appeals board
okay
not relative to housing appeals board
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to
legislators into marjorie smith for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
committee on judiciary to which was
referred house bill 1-2-6-0 when that
making immunization status a protected
class having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that is in expedia to legislate
since charlotte d lorenzo for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committed
report is adopted
committee on judiciary to which has
referred house bill 1408 an act
requiring the refund of residential
tennessee application fees having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate senator michael
silvia for the committee are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on labor
industrial rehabilitative services to
which was referred cacr 14
an act relating to unions providing that
all workers have the right to join a
union
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate senator
linda turcotte for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being able to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative donald bouchard from
the minority of the committee
this is a one-on-one debate
chair recognizes representative bouchard
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
and thank you members of the house for
listening to my testimony in opposition
of the motion
oh you can't hear me oh
thank you mr speaker
and thank you members of the house for
listening to my testimony in opposition
of the motion
to
inexpedient to legislate
this amendment
to the new hampshire constitution will
ensure
forever the collective rights
that are necessary to protect
our individual rights
the right to form a collective union
which will facilitate and enhance the
ability of their members
to exercise
core civil liberties
such as the rights of association speech
and as well petition
this amendment will protect the rights
of individuals forever
to come together over issues
of mutual interests
to protect the right to communicate
forever with co-workers about workplace
concerns to come from the statutory
right to join a union
and bargain collectively
as well as defending the rights of their
members forever
including by lobbying the government to
defend the interests of the overall
membership and by doing
and by going to court to protect the
rights of individual members
in closing mr speaker this amendment
will end the vehement anti-union
crusades in new hampshire forever
i urge the members of this house to vote
against the motion to
in expedient to legislate so a new
motion can be made to make this
constitutional amendment possible thank
you mr speaker
speak in favor of the committee report
thank you mr speaker
good morning
i want to start by reading what the
actual the
cacr would read all workers within this
state shall have the right to join
a union
first of all this is overly broad and
extremely poorly drafted
number two it would allow the way it's
written anyone to join any union
so if i'm working at dunkin donuts can i
demand that i become a member of the
teamsters if i'm working at walmart can
i
demand to become a member of the piper's
local
pipefitters local not pipers
we had absolutely no one testify at our
hearings stating that they had ever been
denied entry into a union where actually
a union was certified and existed
the national labor relations act and the
railway labor act already address
what this again poorly drafted
amendment would attempt to do
furthermore there's costs associated
with putting this on the ballot that
every town city and
in our entire state would have to be uh
would have to endure
by putting it on their ballots and
finally
it simply does not belong in our
constitution
uh
our new hampshire constitution
is a i would almost call a sacred
document
and this certainly is unworthy of being
in that document thank you
representative has requested a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
um
for ice cream
the motion before us is the majority
report have been expanding to legislate
on cacr 14.
this is a division this is a roll call
vote
chair recognizes representative bouchard
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
and mr speaker if i know
that this amendment will protect our
collective and individual rights
and mr speaker if i know that this
amendment will protect the right to form
a collective union
then mr speaker would i press the red
button so that someone can make
another motion
thank you mr speaker
chair recognize representative turcotte
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that the
nrla and the rla already address
what this cacr hopes to accomplish
and if i know that this is a bill
drafted for the purposes of a feel-good
optics and one that will cost taxpayers
money to place on the ballot statewide
and lastly if i know the sponsors could
not produce a single instance or any
testimony of anyone being denied entry
into a union to which they were entitled
to join
would have now pressed the green button
to support the majority position of
inexpedient to legislate thank you mr
speaker
the question before us
is the majority committed report of
inexpensive legislate on cacr 14. this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
this
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
182 voting a
159 voting nay
it does not
get the necessary votes to pass
the itl passes
majority of committee on labor
industrial and real potato services to
which was referred house bill 1385 an
act prohibiting the use of credit
history and employment division
decisions have been considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate senator brian seaworth from
the majority of the committee are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
it is given awful noisy in here again
majority of the committee on municipal
and county government to which was
referred house bill 1275
and act relative to municipal
representation on regional planning
commissions having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislative representative richard
tripp for the majority of the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the i have the eyes have it and the
committee report is adopted
majority of the committee on municipal
and county government to which was
referred house bill 1387 enact enabling
municipalities to adopt a property tax
homestead exemption having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate senator richard
loseles for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being an
unknowable degree with the majority
report with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass senate ivy bond for
the minority of the committee
this is a
one-on-one debate the chair recognizes
representative reid to speak against the
committee report
thank you mr speaker
while i don't really have hope to
overturn the committee recommendation i
did want to take the opportunity to
introduce the idea of this bill to the
house
because i think it's a really powerful
idea to address two major crises that we
have in the state the first is the
graying of new hampshire
where we cannot attract and keep young
people in this state and the second is
the home the housing crisis which is the
predominant contributor to the first
crisis
property taxes are at the heart of the
cause
i won't say of the entire housing crisis
but certainly for young people people in
transition elderly people
property taxes are a regressive tax
structure that penalize
people out of an ability to just buy a
home a modest home something i think we
should all be supportive of because we
know increased homeownership increases
all kinds of good outcomes for
communities
this bill would enable the voters who
already control how their taxes are
dealt with in their town they vote up
their taxes if they want
an extra fire engine for example they
already are in control of their own
property taxes this bill would simply
allow them if they so want
to say we're going to provide a
homestead exemption for people who have
one modest home
according to
an area median income that's already in
use
by the new hampshire housing financial
authority financial authority
would just provide that exemption if
they want
now
their
the town doesn't have to recuperate the
costs of that but if they chose to there
are a number of ways available to them
to do that and if they chose to increase
taxes i wanted to know when i was
working on this idea how much that tax
would increase for the people who have a
second home people from out of state who
have a vacation home how much would
their taxes increase if the town chose
to recuperate the cost of this exemption
on them and it turns out i worked with a
mathematician who's the chair of his
department at the college he teaches at
and it turns out because of how
property assessments are distributed in
new hampshire
that increase on those people that are
out of state have second homes here
vacation homes is only eight percent not
eight points eight percent so if
someone's paying a hundred dollars in
property taxes and this is their second
home a vacation home they would be
paying 108 and that would enable the
half of that community because it's a
community by community number it would
enable the half of that community that
are younger
starting out in life
are in transition of some sort of life
transition who otherwise just are not
able to buy a home to live in which i
think is a basic thing we all
have a drive to have own a little home
of our own
that would enable that lower half to to
have their own home for eight extra
dollars
so again i think that if the voters of a
town want to be able to do this want to
distribute
how taxes are placed on people and
increa and allow this exemption to exist
for people to qualify for they should be
able to vote for that
and um that's all i have to say thank
you
do you recognize
oh i'm sorry does the member yield the
questions
the member yields you may inquire
thank you mr speaker and thank you
representative for taking the question
so if i understand the the purpose of
the bill so the bill would provide
an exemption to local property taxes
so is there any restraint on people
receiving the
the discount the exemption on the
property taxes from voting for more
spending that would drive taxes up on
others
i'm sorry are you saying
would the voters be able to prevent
extra spending that drives up taxes is
that what you're asking no my my
question is so so let's say my community
adopts this this program should have
passed and i'm eligible for the
exemption so now i'm getting this
exemption on my property taxes but is
there any control on me being able to
then go to the polls to to vote up
lots of other spending programs that
would raise the taxes on others but not
necessarily on myself
that's that's how our current voting
system works is people go and vote their
interests at the polls whether that
increases taxes on others or them or
neither or both
so that would be no change
thank you
chair recognized reference and sellers
speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
[Music]
if you notice the
vote
for municipal and county
we try to be non-partisan
and come up with a consensus anytime
it's
possible
so in this case
this particular bill
seeks to somewhat remedy the housing
crisis
by giving a 50 percent
easement or
a decrease in assessment
for property taxes
the qualification for that
is that the
home
has to
be less than the typical home
in that community
the second qualification is the income
for the occupants of that
have to be less than the typical
in the community
can you imagine
having to define those two things
in the case of
[Music]
the
assessment
my wife and i live in a in a
very frugal home
my income
we all put income in various pots
sometimes
you can have a lot of income
and it doesn't qualify as income
for adjusted gross
or whatever
in my own case
i have far more
discretionary dollars
than i did when i was young
but i might qualify for this
so i ask you
do not pit
one
property owner
one property tax
payer to against another
even though
the goal
might be
very
commendable
don't do that please follow
the
17 to 2
bipartisan
vote
against this bill
and i thank you
does the member yield to questions
no
member does not yield
question before us
is the majority motion of itl on house
bill 1387
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
we have a request for a division
members be in your seats we have a
legitimate request for a division vote
so
this is going to be a division vote
members take your seats
chair recognizes representative van for
a parliamentary inquiry
house will be in order members be in
your seats
thank you mr speaker and thank you
members of the house if i know that our
current system of property tax is unfair
and inequitable and if i know that many
states have a homestead exemption
and if i know that this is enabling
legislation which would require the town
which adopted it to consider all of the
exemptions currently allowed and decide
at that point which of them they wish to
keep
would i now press
the red button to overturn the
recommendation to itl thank you
i recognize representative dolan for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know this is a well-meaning bill
that attempts to partially solve the
hurdles that young people have when they
attempt to purchase housing
and if i know the homestead provisions
of the bill
would assist in this regard
however if i also know that the imp
impact of removing large portions of
taxable property from the rolls has a
deleterious impact on the other
taxpayers
wouldn't i then support the bipartisan
recommendation of the committee of 17-2
to pass
this itl
and press green
thank you mr speaker
this is a division vote
the motion before us
is the itl motion the majority itl
motion on house bill 1387.
if you
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend the state of the vote
309 voting yay 31 voting nay committee
reports adopted
okay members stay in your seats for a
minute we're going to be taking our
lunch break we have a few things ahead
of time
um
we have a
two announcements and then we'll have a
couple inanimate consents
chair recognizes representative reed for
an announcement
thank you mr speaker this is just a
reminder that there's free ice cream in
the cafeteria you can come try a scoop
or five scoops
there'll be a short presentation on
ranked choice voting especially how it
relates to first the nation and a live
counting hand counting demonstration but
come for the ice cream that's cool too
thank you
the clerk has an announcement thank you
mr speaker
representatives the speakers asked me to
just remind you about house rule 14
while a member is speaking no one shall
pass between that member and the other
members of the house nor shall anyone
engage in private conversation that
means if members are standing at these
two wells you should not be walking in
front of them down these aisles and also
as as he alluded to before several times
there should not be private
conversations in the chamber thank you
mr speaker
the chair recognizes representative lang
for an announcement
thank you mr speaker i don't know if you
noticed but out in the in the ante room
as well as the back door and over at the
lob we have some new hampshire food bank
boxes
as part of the fundraiser for the
softball game i'm engaging corporate
sponsors who will pay us for every pound
of food that the house brings in so if
we can have people for the next 30 days
the boxes will be there we'll take care
of them and if we can fill those up
we'll get money for domestic violence
programs as well as homeless veterans
programs and on top of that our new
hampshire citizens will get the food
from the food bank so if you can
remember over the next 30 days if you're
coming in to bring a couple items drop
them in the box i'd greatly appreciate
it and i'll help out those programs
thank you
chair recognizes representative bone for
unanimous consent
thank you mr speaker
first i would like to thank all that
came to my aid at our last session
i would name names but i would probably
miss someone
i've received a lot of messages as to
who but they included people and
certainly i didn't know
and i also heard that there were two
senators
involved
i guess that if one had a medical
emergency this would be the place
i've heard of cases where someone
collapsed in stores and people just
walked around them knowing we have a lot
of nurses emts and even doctors here as
reps
this would be the place
so i humbly thank you for being there
and providing me with aid
all the thanks to kpo for posting
on facebook letting everyone know and
thus allowing me to comment when my wits
came about me at the hospital
also the lakers for bringing my jeep
home
i will also thank the manchester fire
department for their fast response i
heard they were watching on tv or on
their way before the 9 11 call
cmc was great by the way it was only my
third time that i spent the night at the
hospital been to emergency rooms
day surgeries et cetera only three times
in my life
second i heard that there were a lot of
people that were very upset as to my
emergency
and were upset all that day and even for
days
this caused some mixed emotions i didn't
know there were that many people
concerned about me
guess what was best said in the facebook
post that stated don't ever do that
again
there are a lot of people that respect
and love you
i humbly thank you for your concern it's
always nice to know there are people
that care for you but like i said mixed
emotions also very sorry that i cause
you grief
and i hope this doesn't happen again
now to end with some
tim allen humor
who tore open my shirt
and did anyone find any buttons
thank you
[Music]
chair recognizes representative ammon
for
unanimous consent
mr speaker this will be very brief uh mr
speaker would you believe that we're
excited to be back in the people's house
and doing the people's business so
everyone welcome back to the house and
we're excited
[Applause]
okay we're going to take
an hour's break
we're doing a lot better than we
anticipated
they're
most likely we are going to be taking up
some of the committee conference reports
after we get done with the um
house bills amended by the senate not
committee or conference house bills
amended by the senate uh we're
got about 10 with 10 bills there or so
left
we'll
reconvene at
12 12 45
and i think we can be out of here before
6.
all right
one speaker
[Music]
members take your seats
the committee on public works and
highways to which was referred house
bill 1456-fn
enact relative to hampton marine
memorial having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with amendment
representative michael edgar for the
committee the amendment zero zero three
nine h printed in house record nine
pages 42.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the chair recognizes
representative aker to speak for the
committee report
mr speaker
i rise to speak in favor of
h.b 1456.
it concerns the hampton marine memorial
the hampton marine memorial
is for those service members and also
for those
merchant marine service members who
either lost at sea and their bodies
weren't found or for those that were
buried at sea
this bill increases the
eligibility for inclusion on the
monument
okay we have uh
that would actually include now
according to the bill we would include
uh
desert storm desert shield and also the
war on terrorism you know following
the 9 11 attack
okay this would allow us to put on the
memorial
marine corps
corporal jonathan courier who was lost
it's lost at sea
off of the philippines in
2018.
it would also allow us to put on it
marine corps
captain gary dillon
he was from a concord
who was who was actually lost at sea
after a mid-air collision of his
helicopter doing a night
night training just before
desert storm
he was lost in the arabian sea
so
what i guess i want to add is is that i
um
you know i know jonathan very well he
was a fine young man
thank you for considering the bill
for what reason to memorize
question before the house
is the ought to pass with amendment
motion on house bill 1456
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee report is
adopted
for reason is a member rise
thank you miss thank you mr speaker
mr speaker knowing how hard our friend
from hampton has worked on this bill
and the eloquence of his remarks this
afternoon i'd ask they'd be placed in
the permanent journal
without objections
the committee on state and
federal relations and veterans affairs
to which was referred house bill 1411fn
an act relative to transparency of
federal agency operations within new
hampshire
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
senator william foster for the committee
the amendment
house will come to order it's awful
awful loud
the amendment is
01948 printed in house record nine pages
42.
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say
for what reason is a member rising mr
speaker
for a clarification mr speaker
we have cacr up there 32 it has no
amendments
and some of us are confused
uh well paperwork got a little mixed up
so we are back to
cacr32 and then we'll
committee on state and federal relations
and veterans affairs to which was
referred cacr 32 an act relating to
independence providing that the state
peaceably declares independence from the
united states proceeds as a sovereign
nation having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
senator brodie duchess for the committee
what reason is a member rising uh to
make a motion state your motion
table stage of motion
the motion is taken cog 32 yes
a roll call has been requested that is
sufficiently seconded
[Music]
members will take their seats this will
be a roll call vote
is
so
house will come to water
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on cacr32
the chair recognizes santo notasto for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that is a
long-standing american value that
government requires the consent of the
governed
and if i know
that no new hampshire citizen alive
today gave their consent to be governed
by this federal government
and if i know this bill will give new
hampshire citizens the historic
opportunity to affirm their consent then
i then would i press the red button so
another motion can be made
chair recognizes representative bel
disarro for parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker
if i know
that the representative from weir did a
great job in breaking this down on the
reasons why
this should not go to the voters and mr
speaker
what i know and if you all knew that
there were no rules whatsoever what
would happen to your retirement police
military
funding
uh bases
no rules whatsoever on this and there's
nothing in the constitution then
would i speak
on behalf of all and let's just vote
this table and move on thank you
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on cacr32
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
we're in the voting bone members will
stay in their seats
[Music]
perez
former mr president had an opportunity
to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
162 voting yay 170 voting nay the motion
to table fails
we're back to the initial motion of
inexpedient to legislate
chair recognizes representative tim
smith
to speak
for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
so
this is the the first time i've come up
to the microphone this session and those
of you who've been here for a few terms
realize that i'm someone who comes up to
the microphone a lot
um so i i hope that you'll appreciate
the gravity that it took to get me down
here today
um normally i prepare remarks but not
this time i tried a dozen times to write
a speech for this
but i i just couldn't do it it's too
personal for too many of us here in the
room it's too personal for me
i'm a direct descendant of captain john
smith who fought alongside george
washington
that guy
to establish the united states is an
independent nation
i'm also a direct descendant of sergeant
garrett preston smith who fought in the
u.s civil war
to keep the united states
one nation undivided
lot of folks in this room have similar
stories from their own families have
some similar lineages that they look
back upon
and even if you don't
we have a communal heritage here in new
hampshire
with a unique place
in american history it was new
hampshire's adoption
of the u.s constitution we were the
ninth state
to ratify the u.s constitution which was
the vote that made it official and sent
it into effect
for all of the 13 colonies we did that
it was this state it was new hampshire
that created the united states of
america
fast forward a few decades
we had a civil war
as a few breakaway states decided that
they would rather go do their own thing
and establish a country founded on the
principles of chattel slavery
well new hampshire didn't think that was
such a good idea so we answered
president lincoln's call
that guy
and we sent troops down to put a stop to
that
folks might not realize this but you
know when we walk into this building
through the front foyer
we come in through a room called the
hall of flags
the regimental battle standard
from the new hampshire regiment that
liberated the confederate capital city
of richmond virginia is downstairs on
the first floor of this building
new hampshire liberated the confederate
capital
and worked to it when jefferson davis
and his little cohort ran fleeing with
their tails between their legs they were
running from new hampshire soldiers and
i am proud of that heritage and legacy
that we all carry with us here in this
chamber and every day that we carry on
as an elected official in this state and
all of this this transcends party this
transcends ideology we are americans and
we are from new hampshire
fast forward a few more decades
you know when i first got elected in
2012 there were three things i
absolutely never thought that i would
vote on during my tenure in the new
hampshire house
articles of impeachment and we came
close a couple of years ago we had a
bill called it was a bill of address it
was the first step in an impeachment
proceeding so there was number one
number two was formal disciplinary
actions against members of the house
unfortunately we had that a couple of
years ago
so that was number two and here we are
with number three articles of secession
you know it's it's almost impossible to
even talk about this without breaking
down i mean i apologize for my composure
mr speaker i am close to tears right now
because this is such a deeply personal
issue
you know
we have this legislation in front of us
it is a bill to destroy the united
states
we stand in the shadow
literally of abraham lincoln and george
washington and we are considering
legislation to take a star off of that
flag
every single one of us stood for the
pledge of allegiance in national anthem
this morning every single one of us took
the same oath of office to support and
defend the constitution united states
and we have legislation now seeking to
destroy the constitution of the united
states that is beyond shameful it is
beyond disgraceful and it is a stain on
the proud history of the state that we
even have to entertain this being
introduced through the administrative
process never mind you know getting far
enough along to have a vote on the floor
of the house
it was really close
to the textbook definition under title
18 of the us code
it was really close to the definition of
advocating overthrow of the u.s
government
when the cacr was introduced
when co-sponsors signed on
it was really close to seditious
conspiracy
a vote for this
is really close to the federal
definition of treason
thank you mr speaker
the house will be in order
there's a member yield to questions
member does not yield
the chair recognizes santa natastov to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
the united states is not going to
outlast the sun one day it will end if
you declared in 1985 that the soviet
union would be completely gone in the
next decade you would be considered a
crazy person but in 91 it was gone
the american religion is the u s dollar
our biggest export inflation
few understand the privilege we have had
to create money from nothing and export
our inflation living on the backs of the
rest of the world
when the world stops subsidizing the
dollar the federal government loses
ability to dictate the state's behavior
unable to bribe them with worthless
money and quickly the union will fall
apart
this national divorce is going to happen
it's inevitable and we have an
opportunity to get ahead of it
the historic motion cr
cacr32 calls on for a vote by the new
hampshire citizens on the question of
state independence
at the committee hearing many objections
were raised all which were answered by
the pro-independent citizens who
testified and some which i'll address
again today
the biggest objection alleged is this
whole effort is treasonous that any
moves towards independence for any state
is illegal and unconstitutional
if it were unconstitutional for a state
to secede this prohibition would have
been included in the u.s in the original
constitution for the 9th and 10th
amendments since it's not specifically
included there there is no such
restriction and that power is left to
the states
additionally everything states are not
permitted to do are listed in article 1
section 10 of the constitution it does
not mention anything about separating
from the union therefore it is not
prohibited
and to those who say that per the
articles of confederation this union is
perpetual and that this concept was
adopted by the u.s constitution
we ask has there ever been in history a
union that was undissolvable
the federal government often supports
independence movements in other nations
is the u.s the only perpetual nation in
the history of the world
is there truly nothing the federal
government could do that would allow a
state to declare independence
and even if this move towards
independence is illegal or treasonous
which i do not believe it to be
it would be no more so than the one in
which is celebrated by everybody in this
body to quote from the declaration of
independence
when in the course of human events it
becomes necessary for one people to
dissolve the political bands which have
connected them with another and to
assume among the powers of the earth the
separate and equal station to which the
laws of nature and of nature's god
entitle them a decent respect to the
opinions of mankind requires that they
should declare the causes which impel
them to the separation
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal and they
are endowed by the creator with certain
unanniable rights that among these are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness that to secure these rights
governments are instituted among men
deriving their powers from the consent
of the governed that whatever any form
of government becomes destructive of
these ends it is the right of the people
to alter and or abolish it and to
institute new government laying its
foundation on such principles and
organizing its powers in such form as to
themselves seem the most likely to
affect their safety and happiness
prudence indeed will dictate that
governments long established should not
be changed for light and transient
causes and accordingly all experience
has shown that mankind are more disposed
to suffer
while suffer evils are sufferable than
to write themselves by abolishing the
forms to which they are accustomed but
when a long train of abusers and usurp
patients pursuing invariably the same
object invinces a design to reduce them
under absolute depth-ism it is their
right it is their duty to throw off such
government and to promote and to provide
new guards for their future security
to assert that those who wrote this
document went on to create a government
that contradicts the principles on which
it was founded is ludicrous and absurd
returning to the alleged violation of
the constitution i'm surprised that some
are troubled by violations of the u s
constitution it is not even possible to
list all the violations on the other
part on the other party of this document
making this contract void in the
perspective of any contract law that has
ever existed
there is no evidence that the federal
government is bound by the constitution
does our constitution allow an
intelligence community which to quote
the current senate majority leader has
six ways of sunday of getting back at
you if you cross them
that work so hard to undermine the 45th
president of this country and to assure
the election of our current president
those who oppose this idea because in so
many words the civil war settled that
issue we must assume that how the
colonists lost the war in the 1700s that
their words would not have been
universally and everlasting true that
their veracity depended upon winning a
war
do we believe that other conquering
nations have a right to forcefully rule
over the concord because might makes
right for lack of power do we surrender
the principle of self-determination for
a state any more or less than an
individual
some oppose this because government's
long established should not be changed
for light and transient causes
we are at a point beyond this does
anyone believe that the current powers
of the federal government over every
aspect of our lives from toilets to
light bulbs from taxing taxation to
vaccine mandates from bankrupt social
security to our 30 trillion dollar
deficit the war on drugs border patrols
within 100 miles national borders how
children are taught in our schools and
arbitrary no-fly lists are just light
and transient causes
a federal government with approximately
400 agencies and more laws federal
crimes and rules that anyone in the
country is even aware of a federal
government that has sent our sons and
daughters to foreign countries and
involved them in countless foreign
entanglements often leading to their
deaths
for those who label this effort
unamerican referring back to the
founding declaration of independence but
when a train a long train of abuses and
usurp patients pursuing invariably the
same object invinces a design to reduce
them under absolute depth ism it is
their right it is their duty to throw
off such government
how could one possibly argue that the
words of the declaration of independence
were un-american
for concerns such as what is the plan or
how we will survive there are plenty of
examples of smaller countries in the
world that function independently and
even thrive but also it would be absurd
to just tell a battered wife that she
can't divorce until she has a plan
this is not a fringe idea hashtag
national divorce trends on the internet
there's a similar movement in california
which will flourish again when
republicans take up take the u.s
congress later this year
there's independence movements in texas
and several movements to move borders of
cities as in atlanta or the states as in
the greater idaho movement
hollywood star ron perlman recently
stated
it's time that every state that would
elect republicans to represent them and
all the rest of us separate you don't
want to live in my world and i certainly
don't want to live in yours
sarah silverman has endorsed national
divorce ted cruz and congressman massey
and greene have spoken in support of
national divorce
media personalities including glenn beck
ben shapiro matt walsh temple and others
have spoken in support of splitting up
the union before it's too late
this bill has no one in the chamber
voting directly on secession it asks
them only to to allow those we purport
to represent to make their own decisions
if our state was currently independent
would we choose to join the union in the
situation that it's in
the answer is obviously no so we should
allow our citizens the opportunity to
determine their own future
thank you mr speaker
the house will be in order no
emotion is to be shown from the gallery
or we'll have it cleared does the member
yield the questions
yes i'll deal
representative abramson
do i need to turn this on
no it was
other people
is this on oh there we go
thank you mr speaker and i thank the
member for taking my question do you
believe that the people of the ukraine
have the right to resist soviet military
aggression right now
uh definitely
follow-up this is not anything to do
with the bill
so
if you're going to ask a question ask
about the bill itself
all right can i respond to a remark that
was made by a previous speaker
no that's that's not you're here to ask
a question all right
can i ask it would you believe
it's on topic
it's definitely on topic
you may
would you believe that my grandmother
who just passed away at the age of 99
would tell us stories about the civil
war
and that we had
members of our family on my
grandmother's side who fought in the
civil war
and that they
risked their lives and some of them died
to end slavery not to subject us
to socialist tyranny from a top-down
federal government
uh yes i believe that thank you would
you believe is the member yield of
further questions
uh no questions
yes
no no
remember the member does not yield mr
speaker uh can i ask for a roll call
vote
roll call has been
you already asked the roll call has been
requested
i didn't ask for a second yet but i
guess that is a second
we have one more speaker so members take
your seats
uh the chair recognizes representative
des to speak for the committee report
well
thank you for uh for for indulging mr
speaker and thank you to the members of
the house for for listening and i know
i'll be brief i'll be uh since i'll be
um succinct first let me say i'm amazed
that i must speak as to why this is a
bad idea not only logistically but
constitutionally why this is impossible
why it's improbable and why it's a
violation of our oath to the u.s
constitution into the state of new
hampshire's constitution right
i do not legislate based on hashtags i
do not think we should either just
because something is purportedly
trending which i'm not on twitter so
i've never seen it right but let's be
let's be honest let's be frank about
what this is right now this is a
historic moment not just in the state of
new hampshire but it's a historic moment
in america this is the first time a
legislative body
has debated and will vote upon binding
binding secession
other secession movements that we've
talked about many of those are
non-binding they never get actual votes
and debate on the floor this is binding
it will be the first one debated since
prior to the civil war
that's a historic moment that's also
concerning that we're joining a very bad
group of states that tried to overthrow
the u.s constitution right that tried to
overthrow
a a constitutionally elected in a
constitutionally instituted government i
do not think this body should join such
a group of states we should not be
joining those former confederate states
of america who were deemed treasons
right i see right over my right hand
shoulder here the man who beat back
those who challenged our constitution
and defended it right
the most u.s service members that have
died in any war was the civil war
this body should not be proposing
legislation that could throw us into the
milestone of war
right
into the jaws of certain defeat
it's a terrible thing to do to our
constituents a terrible thing to do to
granite staters so
let's let's also be clear about a number
of other things when we discuss the
constitution because i'm looking at this
strictly from a constitutional issue
right the federal government is the only
legitimate power to admit new states and
extend or attract territorial boundaries
this is quite clear in article 4 section
3 of our state constitution our state
has never within its constitution and
never has the federal government
suggested that states can decide that
they can leave or to join the government
unless the federal government allows so
right there is no process for leaving
this union right the union
as mentioned in texas versus white
just chief justice salmon p chase
[Music]
explained
in his majority decision a 9-0 decision
a new hampshire native in fact same imp
chase was but um
that that
he explained that the union began during
the revolutionary war amongst the
colonies in his decision he writes quote
we confirmed and strengthened and
received
definite form and character and sanction
from the articles of confederation and
by these the union
was solemnly declared to be perpetual
right the articles of confederation of
perpetual union that's the name of the
entire document our country was founded
originally by that document we then
chief justice chase then explains that
the current constitution was ordained to
form a more perfect union and i quote
which extended to convey the idea of
indissoluble unity therefore the union
can never be dissolved anyone who thinks
and reports that they can dissolve the
union single-handedly is wrong
right
let's also discuss the idea that this is
a referendum this is no mere referendum
new hampshire has no referendum
we have no state statute nothing in our
state constitution that suggests that we
have a referendum right we have a
constitutional process for amending the
constitution i look at it this way
this is a race right if you run a 5k
you go each kilometer right kilometer
one was the committee which by the way
rejected this 21 to nothing recognizing
it was unconstitutional in un-american
right step two is we go to the house
floor and we vote on it right every step
along the way that you continue to
complete this 5k is aiding and abetting
and making this policy come to fruition
right by bringing this to the people we
are aiding and abetting in the process
of undermining the u.s constitution and
violating our oaths of office right and
i could go on regarding the 14th
amendment in a myriad of you know this
open question of what is rebellion which
is not defined in the us constitution
which quite frankly after this vote and
now that it's roll called there is a
question of what do we do and how do we
enforce the 14th amendment which we took
an oath to the constitution of
and i hope
i hope that we don't have to be
answering that question on the house
floor in the future i hope that everyone
says no to this constitutional amendment
because i would prefer not to see the
partisan politics of trying to remove
members of this house for
arguably maybe violating their
constitutional oath right
it's deeply concerning to me
and so i hope that we can reject this i
hope we can stick with constitutional
government i hope that we can uphold the
u.s constitution i hope we can continue
to uphold the new hampshire state
constitution
we should support the union today
the union tomorrow
in the union forever
thank you
does the member yield to questions
yes
member yields
senator klein knight you may inquire
um thank you so much representative for
taking my question
has have any of your colleagues decided
on who's going to run for president of
new hampshire
that that is not an appropriate question
we've had a request for a roll call
and now i'm going to ask is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded members will
take their seats this will be a roll
call vote
so
the house will come to water
the question before us
is the motion of itl on
cacr32 this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
sylvia for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that new hampshire
did not delegate to the united states
a power to prevent
peaceful
separation
and that the tenth amendment to the u s
constitution recognizes
the powers not delegated to the united
states by the constitution
nor prohibited
by it to the states
are reserved to the states respectively
or to the people
mr speaker
if i know
that rebellion
and insurrection
are violent
actions
that stand in sharp
contrast
to the deliberative
thoughtful
and cordial process
brought by sponsors and supporters of
this amendment
and mr speaker
if i know no member of this body
should be threatened
with retribution
for their vote here today
and we should all take to heart the
words
of article 30 of our constitution
the freedom of deliberation speech and
debate
in either house of this legislature
is so essential
to the rights of the people
that it cannot be the foundation of any
action complaint prosecution in any
other court or place whatsoever
and mr speaker finally
if i know
that this amendment reinforces article 7
of our constitution which declared new
hampshire to be forever
a free
sovereign
and independent state
then mr speaker would i press the red
button
to stop
the abuse of distant
illegitimate powers thank you mr speaker
the chair recognizes representative bell
desirable for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker as i've
flown back into new hampshire a couple
nights ago from florida i recognize
there's no rebellion
and mr speaker if i know when i walk up
to the state house and i see general
stock out there he's rolling over in his
grave to see what's going on to you
today and mr speaker if you believe as i
do
this move today is unconstitutional it
is an embarrassment for me to even get
up here it is a 21 to nothing vote in my
committee
and that we as an americans should stand
tall and especially for those that shed
blood that made the ultimate sacrifice
mr speaker and mr speaker if they
believe as i do then vote green
and let's move on and get this done
thank you
house will come to water
the motion before us
is the itl motion on cacr32
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
represent rich
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
[Music]
323 voting yay 13 voting nay
committee report
is adopted
mr speaker
what reason does a member rise i asked
that the remarks of the previous debate
be placed in the permanent journal
the question before the house whether
the remark should be printed in the
permanent journal
are you ready for the
a division has been requested members
will take your seats
request for a roll call
representative suffocatious has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
if you have if you have a parliamentary
inquiry you'll have to come down here
unlike unlike
when we were off campus you come to the
well now
thank you mr speaker i'm just asking is
this to print the remarks of everybody
on this bill
yes okay thank you yes
the question before us
is the print
the remarks of this debate in the
permanent journal
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
the state of the vote
278 voting yay
62 vonnie nay the remarks will be
printed in the permanent journal
i would ask everybody to stay in their
seats
the next bill is a division vote with no
debate just
parliamentary inquiries
committee on state and federal relations
and veterans affairs to which was
referred house bill 1411fn
act relative to transparency of federal
agency operations within new hampshire
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
senator william foster for the committee
amendment
0194 194h printed in house record 9 page
42. are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
and the question before us now is the
ought to pass with amendment motion
on
house bill 1411fn
this is a division vote members take
your seats
we have parliamentary inquiries only
okay
the chair recognizes representative
lawton for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i know
that this bill
would put a further
unnecessary strain
on an already strained department of
justice and if i know
that this bill could have a harmful
impact
on the privacy of refugees in the
granite state
would i now vote no and push the red
button so that another motion may be
made
gee i recognize representative bell
disarro for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
recognize that the state of new
hampshire has been
on the ball in this house on
transparency from government for many
many years at least that i've been up
here and mr speaker if i know this bill
sets a path for the federal government
to be transparent with the people of new
hampshire would i then vote
the green button thank you
the question before us is the ought to
pass his amended motion on house bill
one four one one this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative suffocatus
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to stay to the vote
240 204 voting yay 134 voting a
committee report is adopted
what reason remember rise
i motion to take house bill 1175 off the
table and i would like to uh motion for
a roll call vote and do a pi on it
was this one that went on today or
house will be in
order representative
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
you want a division vote the division
this will be a division vote
on removing
1175 from the table the chair recognizes
the representative branch for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i believe in liberty and freedom
and if i believe in the united states
constitution
and if i believe that i wrote a really
good speech and that i would love to be
able to give it
and finally if i know that all bills
deserve a good faith debate and vote
would i now press the green button to
allow debate on this bill thank you
i recognized representative abbott for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that during the public hearing
on hb 1175 the committee learned that
there was
several unintended consequences that
would have been the result of hb 1175
becoming law
and mr speaker i know that one of those
unintended consequences
would be that any person
would be able to stand outside the
window of an elementary school classroom
and videotape
the teacher teaching the class of young
children
regardless that person's criminal record
should i go ahead and push that red
button and oppose the motion to remove
hb 1175
from the table
thank you mr speaker
the question before us is removing from
the table house bill 1175
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
roof
representative chase
thank you
listen
of all remember mr president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
state of the vote
50 voting a 288 voting may
the bill stays on the table
this is the last bill on the regular
calendar before we get to the bills
taking off consent
and the bills that are going to be
brought up that will concur and on
concur from the senate
committee on transportation to which was
referred house bill 1138fna
an act exempting the display of a front
license plate on certain vehicles having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate
representative laura tolesky for the
committee
the chair recognizes representative
conley
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker colleagues i rise
against the committee report on hb 1138
this bill would create a waiver system
of the requirement that vehicles have a
numbered front license plate
if it would alter the historic character
the collectibility or devalue a vehicle
the mounting of a front license plate
can have a significant effect on the
value of certain vehicles this is
especially true for collectible cars
higher-end sports cars imported vehicles
that do not have the same license plate
shape
or area to be affixed on the front of
the vehicle
this bill would require exempted
vehicles to display a decal sticker on
the windshield
so that the exemption would be known to
law enforcement
this would be similar to the inspection
sticker that already goes on the
windshield
many states already do not require a
front license plate on vehicles
those vehicles travel our roads
and new hampshire permits cities and
towns to issue commemorative license
plates which may be displayed
in lieu of a front license plate during
an anniversary or other special event
in fact the gift shop downstairs in the
capital sold commemorative front license
plates in 2019
marking the bicentennial of this very
building and they're still for sale
today
i ask you would these plates be sold in
the capital
if there were safety issues issues with
easy pass readers
or any other concerns raised by the
majority the answer of course is no
this bill is completely voluntary it
does not eliminate front license plates
it is intended not to be a general
exemption for everybody but for certain
vehicles in certain circumstances if the
owner of the vehicle
follows a number of steps that are
prescribed in the bill
the burden of proof is on the applicant
and the bill requires
they provide supporting information for
their exemption request from a
professional in the industry
this is limited this is voluntary i ask
that you vote no on the itl motion so
another motion could be made thank you
is a member yield to questions
remember yields you may inquire
so in the last snowstorm
i was looking
i was looking and i noticed that i
couldn't see
any or be able to read any front license
plates because they were covered by snow
and i could read all the rear license
plates so do you think
that would be much different than having
no front license plate
thank you for the question
representative there are circumstances
like the one you described where the
front license plate is obscured yes
chair recognizes representative crawford
to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker house bill 1138
would exempt the display of a front
license plate on certain vehicles the
bipartisan majority of the committee
agreed this this bill had many problems
the law enforcement community testified
to the importance of vehicles having a
front plate
notwithstanding identifying vehicles for
amber alerts bowler alerts and
identification by witnesses and security
cameras
the dmv testified that the bill's
wording would make it unenforceable
due to the subjective nature of what is
a valuable
or collectible vehicle there would also
be loss of revenue to the state
because we still have toll booths that
are equipped with front plate cameras
only
for these reasons and more the committee
voted 15 to 3 to itl this bill thank you
mr speaker
the motion before us is the committee
report been explaining to legislate on
house bill 1138
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested i was
waiting for that
representative osborne has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
the motion before us the house will come
to water
the motion before us is inexpensive to
legislate on house bill 1138 this is
going to be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
warden for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that mounting of a
front license plate can have a negative
and a significant negative impact on the
collectibility the historic character or
the value of certain rare vehicles
and if i know that vehicles without
front plates are already in our roads
both out of state vehicles as well as
many new hampshire cars
and if i believe that the fears of
police being unable to identify vehicles
easily is unlikely to be a major problem
with unique distinct and rare vehicles
that would take advantage of this
exemption
and mr speaker if i know that any new
hampshire vehicle owner can go out and
buy a commemorative plate
for the front of the car that does not
uniquely identify that vehicle today and
legally drive with it then would i now
press the red button so that another
motion may be made
thank you mr speaker joe recognizes
representative toleski for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill has a number of
problems with ambiguous language poorly
defined terms as well as open-ended
questions on enforcement process and an
interminable loss of toll revenues
and if i know
that law enforcement testified strongly
on the importance of front plates for
amber alerts witness identification and
other important public safety issues
would i then press the green button and
support the 15-3 bipartisan
recommendation of itl thank you mr
speaker
the question before us is the
motion of ito on house bill 1138
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your post you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
goalie
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
226 voting yay 114 voting a committee
report is adopted
yes
the house recognizes the clerk
mr speaker the senate concurs of the
house and the passage of the following
entitled bill with amendment and the
passage of which amendment the senate
has the concurrence of the house
house bill 233 establishing a committee
to study the right of any infant born
alive to medically appropriate and
reasonable care and treatment
representative gordon moves to
non-concur and has recognized his speed
for his
uh further motion
yes house bill
233 was a bill which we
passed sent over to the senate it was
relative to the right of an informed
infant born alive to medically
appropriate reasonable care and
treatment
we sent that over
with the intention of protecting life of
infants born alive
the senate took the bill
and simply
took out the entire text of the bill and
replaced it with a study committee
and
it's a type of issue where i'm not sure
i think most people have their minds
made up
it's not a issue that requires study
and i think we could non-concur with the
bill and would recommend that we
non-concur
the motion before us do non-concur
on house bill 233-fn
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it
and the bill
is not concurred
further senate message mr speaker the
senate concurs the house in the passage
of the following entitled bill with
amendment the passage of which amendment
the senate has the concurrence of the
house house bill 440 prohibiting the
suspension of civil liberties during a
state of emergency
for what reason is
stay true and great
uh mr mr speaker uh we have quite a few
new people and some older people with
really bad memories i think i think what
we're doing now is we received bills
from the senate and were concurring or
non-concurring could you could you
please explain this process to us so
that the folks that don't really know
what we're doing right now have a better
clue
these these are house bills that were
amended by the senate and they were
listed in the calendar
their house bills
these are the ones
these are these are the bills coming
back from the senate yes that were
amended over in the senate
that's why the the chairman will get up
and ask either to concur non-concur or
non-concur and go to a committee
conference
rep
representative gordon moves to concur
and is recognized to speak for his
motion
what reason does the member rise
could i ask a further point of
clarification following on the last one
state you're in gray
could you explain to the body for the
benefit of anybody who is confused what
the effect of a non-concurrence is
if we non-concur
we kill the bill if we concur
we accept the senate amendment
and pass the bill
if we non-concur and go to committee a
conference
we set up a committee conference and
hopefully the senate agrees to a
committee a conference and then the
senate and house will sit down
and um
and
and talk the bill through and to see
what decision they come up with it could
be non-concur concur or
that's about it after the committee
conference one of the two
the chair recognized representative
gordon
thank you mr speaker
house bill 440 was a bill relative to
the suspension of civil liberties during
a state of emergency
we passed that bill over to the senate
the
the purpose of the bill was to make sure
that when we did have a suspension
for an emergency that people's civil
rights and constitutional rights both
state and federal would be protected
the bill went over to the senate the
senate amended the bill
their amendment took out
two pages of findings
and a statement of purpose
but contains the entire
substance of the bill
so i recommend that we the committee
recommends that we concur with the bill
as the substance is still there
thank you
the motion before is this occur on
on house bill 440.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed may
the eyes have it and
the committee report
is adopted we concur
for the senate message
mr speaker the senate concurs with the
house and the passage of the following
entitled bill with amendment the passage
of which amendment the senate has the
concurrence of the house house bill 50
apportioning state representative
districts
representative barbara griffin moves
that we concur the chair recognizes
i'm sorry representative bergeron to
speak against the concurrence
thank you mr speaker this pertains to
house bill 50 which deals with the
redistricting for this body so the
bill's contents
affects everybody in this room
traditionally the senate has done the
redistricting for senate districts
and the house has concurred the house
has done the redistricting for house
districts and the senate has concurred
but not this time
the senate has changed the house
districts in five of the state's ten
counties
in coast county the proposed changes
impact the towns of carroll jefferson
kilkenny and whitefield
in rockingham county there are nine
districts with new configurations
in hillsborough county changes affect 15
towns
amherst brookline goffstown greenville
hollis lineborough mason milford mount
vernon new boston new ipswich schlemberg
temple ware and wilton
throughout the redistricting process we
heard calls for fair and transparent
redistricting in new hampshire
but there were no subcommittees
appointed to work on the maps
subcommittees that would have worked in
open public meetings
maps were drawn behind closed doors and
brought out for a vote before the
committee
now we're being asked to rubber stamp
the changes the senate made to house
maps
without giving you or the public
an opportunity to hear about those
changes or those proposals
do the changes make sense for the
communities that will be affected do
they make sense for you do they make
sense for your communities we don't know
there are significant changes
therefore i urge the membership to vote
against the motion to concur so that a
subsequent motion to appoint a committee
of conference may be made thank you
chair recognizes barbara griffin
thank you mr speaker
hb 50 is before this body for a second
time
you have passed this bill previously
this bill deals with the apportionment
that is required by the federal census
and it deals with your state
representative districts
the senate did change it
you've already heard here today that the
senate does that they change things
occasionally that we send over
and we often agree with them
in this particular case the changes that
were made to the maps that you have
approved for the districts that will
define who sits here next session
were done at the request
of certain members of the house
they were done at the request of members
of the house for reasons that this body
knew
were going to happen after the vote we
have already taken to pass the state
representative maps
the primary reason for the need for
those changes is that we have cities
and the wards in those cities also need
to be redistricted
and their timetable for doing that work
is outside of the calendar we have to do
our work
and accordingly wards in cities changed
so for example
in hillsborough county where the
representative from nashua just referred
to changes that were made
the major city in hillsborough county
manchester the wards changed
significantly enough that it required
changes in abutting districts to
continue to meet the requirement for
the
apportionment of population and to stay
within an acceptable deviation
in other counties where there were
changes made it was to better comply
with the constitutional requirement that
provides that where possible we have as
many single community-based districts
with their own representatives and
indeed with some of the changes in
further reflection those changes were
able to be made
the changes that were made by the senate
were requested by members of this body
and they
they make sense
they meet the federal requirements and
they continue to do the job that we will
need to do for the citizens of new
hampshire over the next 10 years i ask
for your support
in the request before you to concur with
the senate changes thank you mr speaker
does the member yield to questions
no i do not remember does not yield
the motion before us is to concur
on house bill 50.
i
a division
a division has been requested
[Music]
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote i
was waiting for that
the promotion before us is to concur on
house bill 50.
this will be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
bergeron for a parliamentary inquiry
house will be in order
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the senate has
amended house districts in five of the
state's 10 counties and if i know that
members of this house and their
constituents deserve an opportunity
to hear more about those proposed
changes but i now vote no and push the
red button so that a subsequent motion
can be made to send this to a committee
of conference thank you
jerick and as representative
representative barbara griffin for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the changes proposed by
the senate have been noticed in the
calendar for weeks and have been online
for review for all members of this
body to determine that indeed they make
sense and if i know that the changes do
continue to ensure that the maps comply
with all constitutional requirements at
the state
and federal levels and finally mr
speaker if i know that these changes
make sense for new hampshire would i now
concur
with the changes made by the senate and
press the green button thank you mr
speaker
the motion before us is to concur on
house bill 50. this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
representative kaplan
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
also attend the state of the vote
172 voting yay 163 voting nay
the
report
concurring on house bill 50 is adopted
further senate message mr speaker the
senate concurs the house and the pastor
of the following entitled bill with
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the senate has the concurrence
of the house house bill 55 apportioning
delegates to state party conventions and
relative to the forum for declarations
of candidacy for delegates to state
party conventions
presented griffin barbara griffin moves
that we can curb and is recognized to
speak
thank you mr speaker hb 55 a bill
previously passed by this house deals
with the
process for the parties to determine
delegates to the state convention
the changes made by the senate were
requested by house members
in regards to the fact that when the
changes were done in this body
there was a portion of the statute that
was not changed there were actually two
components to this how the delegates are
determined
the delegates will be determined based
on your representative maps but there's
also an actual ballot form in the
statute which was not included in the
original bill so the senate at the
request of the house has now included
that making the changes complete and we
are able to would be able to now
implement them fully for the next
decennial period thank you
the question before is his concurrence
on house bill 55 are you ready for the
question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and
the bill is
adopted all
presiding has right
got it
all right the house will attend to bills
removed from the consent calendar
the committee on children and family law
to which was referred house bill 1436 fn
and acts relative to appeals of family
court decisions having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative jody nelson
for the committee
this will be a one-on-one debate
the member from wilton representative
cofolt is recognized to speak against
the committee report
i'm sorry what
for what reason does a member rise
mr speaker i rise to make a motion
state your motion my motion is to table
house bill 1436
representative simone moves that house
bill 1436 be late on the table are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and it's laid on the
table
all right
the committee on children and family law
which was referred house bill 1651 fn an
act adding sexual reassignment to the
definition of child abuse having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that it
is inexpedient to legislate
representative kimberly rice for the
committee for what reason does a member
rise
thank you mr speaker i rise to make a
motion
state your motion
i move that we table
this bill
representative diesel moon moves at
hospital 1651 be laid on the table are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and house bill 1651 is
laid on the table
the committee on election law which was
referred house bill
1149 and act relative to the number of
names required for nomination by
nomination papers having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative fenton grown
for the committee
this is a one-on-one rep the member from
seabrook representative abramson is
recognized to speak against the
committee report
uh mr speaker i did this as a
parliamentary inquiry but i can do it as
a very short speech either way fair
enough
thank
you whatever saves time is a consent
calendar bill
uh thank you mr speaker i rise in
opposition to the itl motion on this
bill
the bill would effectively reduce the
signatures needed for minor parties from
over six thousand signatures to two
thousand
since the uh you need three thousand
valid signatures fifteen hundred from
each congressional district and that
effectively means that all minor parties
and independent candidates need
uh to turn in over six thousand to be
sure this would reduce that uh
insane burden from 6 000 to just about 2
these minor parties and indica
independent candidates get on the ballot
anyway
about 90 percent of the time
minor parties
in gathering signatures
end up having to interact with between
fifty and sixty thousand voters who ask
why are we having to sign this and the
minor party activists holding clipboard
always say
basically
the two parties block ballot access to
minor parties and don't have to get any
signatures themselves to get on the
ballot and the voters almost always find
that to be extremely unfair and is very
aggravating
requiring
interacting with 60 000 people to get
signatures is dangerous in the age of
coronavirus and who knows what it's
going to evolve into or adapt to in the
next election cycle
and most states only require
about one percent
for ballot access or less so current law
aggravates independent voters who
support ballot access by a margin of
three to one
so please vote red so that we can
overturn this and pass some version of
this bill
the member from salem representative
sweeney is recognized to speak in favor
of the committee report
thank you mr speaker thank you everyone
welcome back to the new hampshire house
this bill we are very generous in new
hampshire as it currently stands with
the
rules and regulations we put in forth to
allow parties to gain access to the
ballot to place their candidates names
on without nomination papers
being on the ballot is a privilege in
this state to print the names on ballots
across the state of new hampshire should
have a threshold that is reasonable
which we currently have
and i would just urge the body to vote
against this legislation
and agree with the unanimous bipartisan
recommendation of the election law
committee to vote this down thank you
the questions on the majority committee
report of inexpedience legislate
representative abramson requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members please take
your seats
so
the house will come to order
and members should be in their seats
there are no pis
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
uh
so
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
283 having voted in the affirmative 43
on the negative the committee reports
adopted
the committee on election ladder which
was referred house bill 1197 and act
relative to the definition of party for
election purposes having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that has an
expedient to legislate representative
joe sweeney for the committee for what
reason does the member rise
for a motion
state your motion i move to table
representative bolden moves that house
bill 1197 be laid upon the table are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and house bill 1197 is
laid on the table
the committee on executive departments
and administrations which was deferred
house bill 1443
an act proclaiming the first monday of
march as covet 19 victims and survivors
memorial day
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative chasey groat
for the committee apologize if i
butchered that
for what reason does a member rise
for a motion please state your motion i
move to put house bill 1443 on the table
representative mcguire moves at house
bill 1443 be late on the table are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and 1443 is laid on the
table
house will be in order
the committee on labor industrial and
rehabilitative services which is
referred house bill 1124 an act
requiring businesses to use the federal
e-verify system of the united states
citizenship and immigration services
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative brian sullivan
for the committee
the member from southampton
representative bernardi is recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
the current motion asks that we reject
the implementation of the e-verify
system
e-verify is a free web-based system that
allows employers to verify the
information provided on a prospective
employee's form i-9 the federally
required employment eligibility
verification form
e-verify electronically matches
the i-9
information against the social security
administration
and the department of homeland
security's databases
when initiated in 2012
the system was slow
and had
unacceptable error rate
it had a major upgrade two and a half
years ago the end of
2018.
the system now confirms most records
within three to five seconds and nearly
all records in 24 hours
modernization improved usability reduced
errors increased speed and accuracy and
implemented a modernized database
it is rated as one of the federal
government's highest rated services for
user satisfaction
e-verify is used in nearly 1 milli by 1
million employees employers excuse me of
all sizes and 2.4 million hiring sites
in 22 states and by most federal
contractors and subcontractors
the latest state to
sign on has been florida
enforcement under this bill would be
through the current civil penalties and
administrative provisions in section
275a
of new hampshire's current labor law
the same section already authorizes the
use of e-verify for voluntary
verification of prospective employers
social security number
please join me in implementing this fast
free and accurate method to ensure we
maintain a legal workforce in new
hampshire push the red button so that
another motion can be made
the member from grantham representative
sullivan is recognized to speak in
support of the committee report
thank you mr speaker
the e-verify system well let me start by
saying this
bill was
voted itl by the labor committee twenty
to one
it is a strong bipartisan rejection of
this the system
the the committee felt that the
testimony we received indicated there
are still accuracy issues with the
system and that
some of the more complicated names
especially ethnic names
are sometimes
missed by the system
once a name is rejected
then that individual cannot work in new
hampshire
until the error is fixed and that
sometimes takes weeks
so
we believe that the i-9 system that's
presently in case
in in force
is an effective system we believe this
mandate on employers is unnecessary and
we ask you to vote no
we ask you to vote in favor of the itl
sorry
the question before the house is the
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on house bill 1124.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report's adopted
the committee on resources recreation
and development which was referred to
house bill 1555 fn an act repealing the
permit required for fires at campgrounds
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study
representative jim crichton for the
committee
what reason does a member rise
for a motion please state your motion
i move the table
representative renzulo moves at house
bill 1555 be laid on the table are you
ready for the question
representative bert has requested a roll
call is it sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members please take
your seats
so
the house will come to order
the question before the house is whether
to lay house bill 1555 on the table
representative burke is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker
if i know
that if anybody in this room pulls off
consent it's going to be tabled
that's an option
mr speaker if i know
that this bill should be debated
on the house floor with two speeches
and mr speaker
if i know only one person in the
committee spoke against this bill
and that's why i want this bill pulled
from consent
and lastly mr speaker
if anybody in this room pulls a consent
a bill off consent
they can table it and you will not have
your chance to come up and speak in
front of you would you now vote
red
and please
override this table in motion thank you
mr speaker
representative renzullo is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
no who is it
hi there
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
that the resources committee listened to
the testimony on this bill one person in
favor and every fire marshal and fire
chief opposed
and if i know that interim study is the
only way
to
that interim study was the almost
unanimous vote of the committee
but the tabling will shorten our day
here when i now support the tabling
motion
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1555 on the table if you're in
favor you'll be pressing the green
button if you're opposed you'll be
pressing the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
remember
representative
representative told
up or down
representative tucker
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend the state of the
vote
199 having voted in the affirmative 131
in the negative house bill 1555 is laid
on the table
committee on ways and means to which was
referred house bill 1509 fn an act
relative
to termination of frm victims
contribution recovery fund having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that
it's inexpedient to legislative
representative patrick lebroni for the
committee
chair recognizes representative abrami
i'd like to make a motion to table house
bill 1509
representative moves that we table house
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
in 1509 is laid on the table
the chair recognizes the member from
auburn representative osborne for the
third reading motion
resolved that the house now adjourned
from the early session that the business
of the late session be in order at the
present time that the reading of bills
be by title only in resolutions by
caption only and that all bills ordered
a third reading be read a third time by
this resolution and that all titles
bills be the same as adopted and that
they be passed at the present time and
when the house adjourns today it'd be to
meet tuesday march 15th
2022 at 10 a.m
we're almost done can we have
the house be in order
are you ready for the question on the
third reading motion
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
uh i i want to just let everybody know
what the tentative schedule for next
week is
we are planning on
going through
as is in the calendar tuesday wednesday
and thursday
we have approximately 150 bills on the
regular calendar
so that's approximately 50 bills a day
and if everybody is as good as they were
today
we should be very good next week
and i really want to thank everybody for
getting us through today as as we have
gotten through today
announcements
representative reed
thank you mr speaker for those of you
burning with curiosity salted caramel
blondie
narrowly eked out the victory over
chocolate chip cookie dough they were
the two front runners in the beginning
the first round had salted caramel
blondie by about 30 percent but it comes
out that if everybody had only voted
between those two top two front runners
salted caramel blondie would have gotten
55 which is what the final round showed
that's how it works and i just wanted to
let you know
the clerk has some announcements thank
you mr speaker
we do have uh youth and government
coming in over the weekend so i would
ask that you please clear out your seat
pockets
youth and government is coming in over
the weekend so please clean out your
seat pockets and if you haven't visited
your mailbox is out back please do so we
do have a request for unanimous consent
please be mindful
representative osborne moves at the
house stan
chair recognized representative abramson
for unanimous consent
representative rosman moves at the house
stand in recess for the purpose of the
introduction of bills enrolled billed
amendments enrolled bills reports and
receiving messages are you ready for the
question all those in favor say hi
those those opposed nay the eyes have it
and the motion is adopted
the house will stand in recess until
march
tuesday march 15th at 10 a.m
press please press your buttons to
register for mileage
you